GENTLEMEN.
WELCOME TO THE COMMITTEE ON
ENTER YOU ENERGY UTILITIES AND
TELECOMMUNICATIONS.
WE'RE GONNA GET STARTED AS A SUB
COMMITTEE -- TO HEAR TESTIMONY
ON TODAY'S AGENDA -- WE'RE GONNA
START WITH US SENATOR CARL YET
ALL -- SB FIVE ONE FIVE
CALIFORNIA CALIFORNIA RENEWABLES
PORTFOLIO STANDARD PROGRAM.
WELCOME GOOD MORNING.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT SB FIVE
ONE FIVE WHICH IS A NARROWLY
FOCUSED BILL.
THAT WOULD EXPAND THE DEFINITION
OF HIGH HAZARD FUEL FOR BIOMASS
FACILITIES WITH BIRAM CONTRACTS.
IN TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN THEN
GOVERNOR JERRY BROWN ISSUED AN
EMERGENCY PROCLAMATION CALLING
FOR THE CPUC. TO ADDRESS THE
ISSUE OF EXPIRING BIOMASS
CONTRACTS AS PART OF THE CONCERN
THAT AT THE TIME CALIFORNIA HAD
AN ESTIMATED. HUNDRED AND TWO
MILLION DEAD OR DYING TREES.
HELLFIRE PUT TOGETHER A MAP
COMIC COMMONLY REFERRED TO AS
HIGH HAZARD ZONE MAP IDENTIFYING
AREAS THAT COULD BE IMPACTED AS
A RESULT OF A DEAD TREE HITTING
A POWER LINE OR BLOCKING THE
ROAD.
THE CPC RESPONDED BY REQUIRING
THE UTILITIES TO PROCURE FIFTY
MEGAWATTS OF BIOMASS ENERGY.
THE LEGISLATURE ALSO ACTED IN
PASSED SB EIGHT FIFTY NINE WHICH
REQUIRED THAT ANOTHER HUNDRED
AND TWENTY FIVE MEGAWATTS OF
BIOMASS ENERGY BE PROCURED.
IN ALL THERE ARE SEVEN CONTRACTS
SIGNED AS A RESULT OF THESE TWO
MANDATES AND THEY REFUSE
REFERRED TO AS BIRAM CONTRACTS.
ALL OF THESE CONTRACTS ARE
REQUIRED TO GET A SPECIFIED
AMOUNT OF FUEL FROM THESE HIGH
HAZARD JONES.
HOWEVER THE UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES OF THIS REQUIREMENT
IF IT FOREST WASTE THAT IS
DEEMED TO BE FROM A HIGH HAZARD
ZONE NOW COST MORE THAN FOREST
WASTE THAT COULD CAUSE A A
WILDFIRE.
SOME OF THESE FACILITIES PAY A
PENALTY BECAUSE THEY CAN'T MEET
THE REQUIREMENTS OF THE HIGH
HAZARD ZONE FUEL WHICH WAS A
RANDOM TARGET SAID ON THE LAST
NIGHT OF SESSION.
WE NO LONGER HAVE A HUNDRED AND
TWO MILLION DEAD TREES IN
CALIFORNIA WE HAVE IT'S AN
ESTIMATED HUNDRED AND FORTY
EIGHT MILLION DEAD TREES.
WE HAVE AN UNHEALTHY AND
OVERSTOCK FOR IS WITH EXCESS
FUELS AND CATASTROPHE IN WAITING
WITH REGARDS TO WILDFIRE.
THE NAPA COUNTY WILDFIRES DIDN'T
CONTAIN THESE HIGH HAZARD JONES
AND NEITHER DID PARADISE RATHER
THAN WAIT UNTIL A DEVASTATING
WILDFIRE DESTROYED THE COMMUNITY
BEFORE REMOVING THE FUEL WE
WOULD LIKE TO GET OUT IN FRONT
OF SOME OF THESE ISSUES AND TRY
TO PREVENT THE NEXT MAJOR
WILDFIRE.
SB FIVE ONE FIVE EXPANDS AND IF
MISSION OF HIGH HAZARD ZONE FUEL
TO INCLUDE THE AREAS WITH IN
AWHILE FIRE SINCE TWO THOUSAND
TWELVE WHICH IS CONSISTENT WITH
WHAT HELLFIRE ANNOUNCED EARLIER
IN THE YEAR.
AS WELL AS EXPANDED TO INCLUDE
CAL FIRES MAP WHICH SHOWS
MODERATE HI AND VERY HIGH HAZARD
ZONES.
THE BILL IS SMALL BUT IMPORTANT.
IT'S AN IMPORTANT STEP TO
IMPROVE THE CONDITIONS AND ARE
FORCED AND HELP PROTECT
COMMUNITIES FROM WILDFIRES WHERE
THERE IS EXCESS FEEL.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. TWO OF THE OTHER SPEAKERS.
GOOD MORNING I'M JEFF OLSON A
REGISTERED PROFESSIONAL FORESTER
WITH CASCADE RESOURCE
CONSULTANTS ON I HANDLE FEEL
PROCUREMENT BERNIE FORCE POWER.
A BIOMASS ENERGY FACILITY IN
EASTERN SHASTA COUNTY AS MY
TESTIMONY WILL FOCUS ON WILDFIRE
PREVENTION ALSO MENTION A SERVER
THE VOLUNTEER FIRE CHIEF OF MY
TOWN AND ON NOVEMBER EIGHTH
ALONG WITH HUNDREDS OF OTHERS.
ENGAGED IN EFFORTS TO HELP SAVE
PARADISE FROM THE CAMPFIRE AN
EXPERIENCE WHICH IS DRAMATICALLY
HEIGHTENED MY SENSE OF URGENCY
FOR REDUCING FIRE RISKS AND OUR
FORESTS.
LIKE MANY BIOMASS FACILITIES IN
TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN BERNIE
FORCE POWER NEARLY CLOSE ITS
DOORS UNTIL WITH SAVE BY THE BY
OUR AND PROGRAM WHICH ALLOWED
PLANS TO CONTINUE OPERATING
WHILE DIRECTING THEM TO SOURCE
MATERIAL FROM HIGH HAZARDS ON
THIS ACCESS TREE MORTALITY.
AT THE TIME THIS MADE SENSE A
HUNDRED TWENTY NINE MILLION
TREES WERE DEAD STATEWIDE
HOWEVER IN TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN
THE STATE WAS RUDELY AWAKENED TO
THE FACT THAT THE GREATEST
THREAT TO OUR FORESTS AND
CITIZENS.
HAD SHIFTED FROM DEAD TREES TO
CATASTROPHIC WILDFIRES CAPABLE
OF WIPING ENTIRE COMMUNITIES OFF
THE MAP IN MERE HOURS.
CASE IN POINT WHEN COOPER MADE
ITS HIGH HAZARD MAPS MULTIPLE
WATERSHEDS COVERING PORTIONS OF
PARADISE AND CON CAL TO NOT HAVE
THE REQUISITE TREE MORTALITY TO
WARRANT.
DESIGNATION AS HIGH HAZARD
FURTHERMORE NOT ONE OF THE
EVACUATION ROUTES OUT OF
PARADISE WAS DESIGNATED AS A
HIGHER PRIORITY TEAR ONE'S OWN.
NEITHER WAS A TRANSMISSION LINE
WHICH ALLEGEDLY STARTED THE
WORST FIRE IN STATE HISTORY.
WITHOUT SUCH DESIGNATION BIOMASS
FACILITIES SUCH AS BERNIE FIND
THEIR HANDS TIED FROM HELPING TO
REDUCTION EFFORTS IN THESE AREAS.
I BELIEVE THESE FACTS ALONE IN
LIGHT OF THE CAMPFIRE ILLUSTRATE
THE THREAT HAS SHIFTED SINCE THE
INCEPTION OF THE POWER AND
PROGRAM.
IN CLOSING I WOULD OFFER THAT
THERE'S CURRENTLY NO VIABLE
ALTERNATIVE TO BOMB OUTS FOR
TREATING OVERSTOCK FORESTS.
THE COMBAT THIS CRISIS I URGE
YOU TO RECOGNIZE THAT THE
PRIORITIES FOR THE POWER IN
PROGRAM MUST ALSO INCLUDE THE
REDUCTION OF CATASTROPHIC
WILDFIRE IN THE STATE WITH SB
FIVE ONE FIVE BEING A STEP IN
THE RIGHT DIRECTION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
JULIE MALINOVSKY BALL
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
BIOMASS ENERGY ALLIANCE -- I
REPRESENT THE OTHER BY AROUND
FACILITIES AND AND I KNOW THAT I
REPRESENT THE INDUSTRY AT HAND
TODAY AND THAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT BUT REALLY WHAT WE'RE
DOING IS REPRESENTING THE
COUNTIES AND THE CITIES AND THE
TO THE REGIONS WHERE THESE
FACILITIES ARE LOCATED.
SO WHEN YOU'RE WHEN YOU'RE
LOOKING AT THE DEFINITION OF A
HIGH HAZARD ZONE YOU'RE TELLING
ONE COMMUNITY HEY ALL YOUR
RESOURCE -- THE WORK THAT YOU'RE
DOING IN YOUR FORCE RIGHT NOW.
SOME OF THIS IS ELIGIBLE TO GO
TO BUY A MASS PLANT BUT YOU TURN
TO ANOTHER COMMUNITY THAT'S
OUTSIDE THAT ZONE AND SAY
EVERYTHING THAT YOUR WORKING ON
TO MAKE YOUR FOREST'S SAFER.
I'M SORRY YOU DON'T HAVE ACCESS
TO THAT BY ON THIS PLAN YOUR
REGION BECAUSE YOU'RE NOT IN A
SPECIAL ZONE.
SO IN IN ONE INSTANCE YOU KNOW
IT'S LKE FIND THEIR BIOMASS
PLANTS WILL FIGURE OUT HOW TO
SURVIVE ONE WAY OR ANOTHER BUT
IT'S THE COMMUNITIES THAT WERE
TRYING TO SUPPORT BY CHANGING
THIS DEFINITION.
WHICH IS WHY WE'RE ASKING FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE TODAY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR COMMITTEE
MEMBERS -- LET ME BE CLEAR ABOUT
WHAT THIS BILL DOES NOT DO --
THIS BILL DOES NOT ALTER ANY
EXISTING UTILITY PURCHASE
CONTRACT.
THIS BILL DOES NOT IMPACT
CONSUMER COST.
THIS BILL DOES NOT ALTER ANY
RULES FOR TIMBER HARVEST OR
CHANGE ANY ENVIRONMENTAL LAW.
WHAT THIS BILL DOES IS ALLOWS
FOR WASTE FROM FIRE PREVENTION
FORCE PROJECTS TO BE EFFICIENTLY
UTILIZED?
AND IT RECOGNIZES THAT
CALIFORNIA'S FORCED MANAGEMENT
GOALS ARE EVOLVING.
WHEN SB EIGHT FIFTY NINE WAS AN
ACTED ARE FORCED ISSUES WHERE
THE DEAD AND DYING TREES IN THIS
YEAR AS?
SO THE BIRAM CONTRACTS COLD FOR
DEALING WITH DEAD TREES.
EARLIER THIS YEAR CAL FIRE
EXPANDED THE CRITERIA. TO
INCLUDE DEAD TREES FROM AREAS
WERE FORCED FIRE HAD OCCURRED.
THIS BILL WOULD EXPAND THE
MATERIAL THAT CAN BE USED IN
BIRAM CONTRACTS FROM THE DEAD
TREES AND THE BURN TREES.
THOSE TREES THAT ARE AT RISK.
THE FORCE FIELD THAT NEED TO BE
REMOVED TO MEET OUR FIRE
PREVENTION GOALS.
LAST EVENING I HAD A CHANCE TO
TALK TO THE COMMITTEE CHAIR
ABOUT PROPOSED AMENDMENTS THAT
HE IS -- SUGGESTING FOR THE BILL.
I WANT TO NOTE THAT WE CAN
SUPPORT ALL OF THOSE AMENDMENTS
WITH ONE MINOR EXCEPTION.
CAL FIRE HAS DEVELOPED A MAP OF
AREAS FOR FIRE RISK.
I WE'RE ASKING THE BIO MASS.
THIS REMOVED FOR FIRE PREVENTION
PURPOSES IN AREAS THAT ARE VERY
HIGH HI AND MODERATE RISK.
BE ALLOWED FOR USE IN THE BIRAM
CONTRACTS.
THE CHAIRS PROPOSE THAT ONLY
MATERIAL IN A VERY HIGH RISK
ZONE BE ALLOWED.
WE ARE WILLING TO ACCEPT THE
REMOVAL OF THE MODERATE RISK
ZONES.
BUT WITH ALL DUE RESPECT WE
WOULD REQUEST THAT DOES THE
COMMITTEE CONTINUE TO INCLUDE.
THE HIGH RISK ZONES.
HIGH RISK ZONES INCLUDE
COMMUNITIES THAT ARE IN THIS
YEAR FOR HILLS ARE OAK WOODLANDS
AND CHAPARRAL ZONES.
THESE ARE OFTEN THE AREAS WHERE
WE SEE THE GREATEST IMPACT OF
WILDLAND URBAN INTERFACE.
SB FIVE FIFTEEN IS ACTUALLY
SIMPLE BILL.
WITHOUT IMPACTING EXISTING
CONTRACTS OR SUPPORT CONSUMER
COSTS IT ALLOWS CALIFORNIA TO
MEET ITS FIRE PREVENTION GOALS
BY FISSION LEE UTILIZING FORCED
WASTE FROM AREAS MOST AT RISK
FOR FIRE.
WE RESPECTFULLY ASK WHEN I VOTE.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS GOT WHICH ON
BEHALF OF THE JOINT LABOR
MANAGEMENT COMMITTEE OF THE
FOREST PRODUCTS INDUSTRY RICHARD
CARPENTERS MILL RICE MACHINISTS
PAPER AND PULP WORKERS IN ABOUT
SIX OTHER UNIONS AND WOOD
PRODUCTS INDUSTRY.
IN ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
COALITION OF UTILITY EMPLOYEES --
CURRENTLY OUR WORKFORCE.
BY IN THE UTILITIES THAT ARE
DOING VEGETATION MANAGEMENT AND
LINE CLEARANCE HAVE TRIPLED IN
THE LAST SIX MONTHS GIVEN THE
MAGNITUDE OF THE WORK.
THIS BILL IS SIGNED TO UTILITIES
BY THE P. YOU SEE TO DO ALL THE
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE ON ALL THE
THE FUEL.
SO WE WENT FOR INSTANCE MPG
THESE SERVICE TERRITORY FROM A
WORKFORCE OF ABOUT A THOUSAND TO
WORK FORCE OF ABOUT.
THREE THOUSAND OUT THERE EVERY
SINGLE DAY CLEARING BRUSH AND
CUTTING TREES.
AND WE DON'T HAVE ANY PLACE TO
PUT IT.
SO WE'RE DOING UTILITIES
OBLIGATION WE'RE CLEARING AT ALL
WE'RE GETTING AWAY FROM THE
LINES AND WE'RE GOING STORIES
SOMEPLACE WHERE IT STILL REMAINS
A FIRE RISK.
WE HAVE TO HAVE A PLACE TO PUT
THE FUEL SO WE URGE AN AYE VOTE
ON THE BILLS -- WITH THE
AMENDMENTS THAT WERE SUGGESTED
BY THE OUR SPONSORS THANK YOU.
AS WITH HER.
RESEARCHER CHRIS FOR KAYLEE ON
BEHALF OF HUMBLE MENDOCINO
REDWOOD COMPANIES ALSO IN
SUPPORT.
KELLY BOYD ON BEHALF CALIFORNIA
LOW CARBON FUEL AND ENERGY
COALITION IN SUPPORT.
BRIAN WHITE ON BEHALF OF THE
FORCE LANDLORDS OF CALIFORNIA
AND CAL FOR LESSONS FORCED
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
MEN'S WEAR MUCH WITH WHAT I MEAN
GROUP ON BEHALF OF I CHECKED OUR
SERVICES AND SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING SYLVIA PRIME BEHALF
HERE PACIFIC INDUSTRIES IN GREEN
DIAMOND SUPPORT.
JOHN KENNEDY ON BEHALF OF THE
RURAL COUNTIES IN SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING THEIR DOLPHIN
HAPPILY TO CALIFORNIA CITIES IN
SUPPORT [inaudible]
ANYONE OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU JEFF.
THANK YOU TURN MEMBERS FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY.
MY NAME IS DANIEL BROUGHT ON
BEHALF OF SIERRA CLUB CALIFORNIA
IN OPPOSITION TO SB.
FIVE ONE FIVE BY MASS
INCINERATION PRODUCES MORE CO
TWO PER MEGAWATT HOUR THAN
FOSSIL FUELS.
BIOMASS INCINERATORS AMID HIGH
VOLUMES OF CRITERIA POLLUTANTS
THAT ARE LINKED TO HEART HEART
AND LUNG CONDITIONS AND ARE
COMPONENTS OF SMOCKS.
IN A OF SMOG ENERGY PRODUCED AND
BY.
IN A BIO MASS INCINERATOR IS
TWICE AS EXPENSIVE AS WINTER
SOLAR.
AND BIOENERGY PROCUREMENT
MANDATES.
THIS PLACE TRULY ZERO EMISSION
ENERGY AT RIGHT SPENCE.
ALL THAT SAID SIERRA CLUB
CALIFORNIA'S.
TURNS WITH THIS BILL FAR EXCEED
OUR GENERAL CONCERNS WITH
BIOMASS INCINERATORS.
THIS BILL WOULD EXPAND THE FEED
STOCKS THAT ARE ELIGIBLE TO MEET
HIGH HAZARD FUEL REQUIREMENTS
FOR BIRAM CONTRACTS.
THESE REQUIREMENTS FR
IMPLEMENTED. TO PRIORITIZE THE
REMOVAL OF TREES THAT THREAT AND
PUBLIC SAFETY.
THIS BILL ESSENTIALLY DESIGNATES
THE ENTIRE FORCES ELIGIBLE
FEEDSTOCK.
IF IT PASSES.
BY MASS INCINERATORS WILL SOURCE
FUEL FROM THE CHEAPEST AREAS
RATHER THAN FROM THE AREAS THAT
POSE THE LARGEST THREAT TO HUMAN
LIVES.
FURTHER THIS BILL OVERSTAFFED A
RECENT CPUC RESOLUTION TO ALLOW
FACILITIES TO COUNT SALVAGE
BIOMASS.
TOWARD THEIR FEEDSTOCK
REQUIREMENTS ON A CASE BY CASE
BASIS SUBJECT TO REVIEW BY THE
COMMISSION.
THE LEGISLATURE SHOULD NOT
INTERFERE WITH HIS COMMONSENSE
AN ECOLOGICALLY CONSCIOUS RULING.
WHEN FIRE BURNS THEIR COMMUNITY
IT MAY BE NECESSARY TO REMOVE
BURNED TREES THAT ARE NOW
FALLING HAZARDS FOR NEARBY HOMES
AND INFRASTRUCTURE?
HOWEVER WHEN A FIRE BURNED A
FIRES OFTEN BURN AND WILD LANDS
MILES AWAY FROM COMMUNITIES.
WHEN THIS IS THE CASE IT IS
UNNECESSARY AND DESTRUCTIVE TO
LOG IN AREA THAT WILL REGENERATE
NATURALLY THAT IS PROVIDING
HABITAT AND THAT A SEQUESTERED
IN CARBON IN LIVING AND DEAD
TREES?
IT IS THEN NONSENSICAL TO LOAD
SEQUESTER CARBON INTO A DIESEL
TRUCK AND INCINERATE IT FOR THE
PRODUCTION OF EXPENSIVE.
AND CARBON INTENSIVE ELECTRICITY
ALL AND RATE PAYERS TIME.
SIERRA CLUB CALIFORNIA IT
SUPPORTS THE AMENDMENTS THAT
WERE IN THE BILL ANALYSIS TO
DIRECT THE CPUC TO DECIDE
WHETHER OR NOT NEW FEEDSTOCK
DESIGNATIONS ARE NECESSARY.
SHORT OF THESE AMENDMENTS SIERRA
CLUB CALIFORNIA OPPOSES SB FIVE
ONE FIVE AND ARE JUST YOU KNOW
ABOUT THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING OF MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE --
NAMES BRENDA WIKI WITH THE
CENTER FOR BIOLOGICAL DIVERSITY
HERE ALSO IN OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL ON THE LIKE TO SOCIO MYSELF
WITH.
BOTH THE THE TO THE LETTER
SUBMITTED BY SIERRA CLUB
CALIFORNIA AND WITH THE COMMENTS
THAT WERE JUST MADE BY DANIEL
AND I'M JUST GONNA HIT ON A FEW
POINTS THAT ARE.
BEYOND WHAT WAS ALREADY WHAT
DOES RT STATED.
I'M ONE OF THE MAIN PURPOSE OF
ONE OF THE MAIN PURPOSES
INTENTIONS STATED THIS BILL IS
TO DIRECT TO MAKE IT POSSIBLE --
FOR FOR BIOMASS TO BE.
CARED FROM FIRES FROM FIRE AREAS
AND I WANT TO MAKE CLEAR THAT IS
ALREADY THE CASE WITHIN OUR
CURRENT LAW.
THAT THE CPC HAS THE DISCRETION
AND HAS BEEN EXERCISING THAT
DISCRETION TO BE ABLE TO ALLOW
CONTRACTS TO TAKE.
FEEDSTOCK FROM THE EXISTING --
FROM A EXISTING CONTRACTS THE
TAKE FEEDSTOCK FROM BURNED AREAS
THAT'S IN AS SOON AS WELL AS
THOSE FIRES HAVE OCCURRED SINCE.
TWENTY TWELVE ALREADY IN THE
THAT'S ALREADY IN THE WORKS AND
HAS BEEN HAPPENING SECONDLY I'D
LIKE TO POINT OUT THAT WHEN WE
ARE TALKING ABOUT ALL OF THOSE
MAPS BUT TOGETHER -- THE HIGH IN
VERY HIGH FIRE THREAD STONES AND
ALSO THE THE TIER ONE AND TIER
TWO AND TIER THREE SAYS --
PRODUCED BY -- BY THE CHIU
MENTALITY TASK FORCE THAN THE
FORCE MANAGEMENT TASK FORCE AND
NOW THE CQC APPROVED WHEN YOU
PUT ALL OF THOSE TOGETHER.
WE ARE TALKING ABOUT MORE THAN
TWO THIRDS OF ALL OF THE
FORESTED AREA IN CALIFORNIA.
WHEN YOU ARE PUTTING OUT A NET?
THAT WIDE THAT TREMENDOUSLY
DILUTES YOUR ABILITY TO FOCUS
THE REMOVALS THE FORCE WOULD
REMOVALS FROM THOSE PLACES THAT
YOUR GAMING TO BE TRULY HIGH
RISK TO SAY THAT WE'RE LOOKING
ACROSS MILLIONS AND MILLIONS OF
ACRES AND NOW ALL OF THOSE WOULD
BE.
AT THE SAME LEVEL OF PRIORITY
COMPLETELY DILUTES OUR ABILITY
TO DIRECT THIS EXPENSIVE.
TOOL TOWARDS REMOVING FAT BM I
AM AS FEEDSTOCK FROM THE FOREST
NOT TO BE CLEAR -- BOMB AT THE
BOMB AS FEEDSTOCK IN MY OPINION
MY ORGANIZATION SHOULD NOT BE A
DRIVING FACTOR FOR OUR
MANAGEMENT DECISIONS IN THE
FOREST IT SHOULD BE A TOOL AND
NOT DRIVING WHERE AND WHEN WE
PULL OUT.
PULL OUT WOULD AND THAT IS VERY
MUCH ARE CONCERNED AS WE LOOK AT
BIO RAM IN THESE TYPES OF
PROJECTS AND SECONDLY THERE IS
MUCH DAMAGE THAT CAN BE DONE.
EVEN IN AREAS WHERE IT'S ALREADY
BURNED -- IF IF YOU'RE NOT
MAKING THESE REMOVALS AS PART OF
A PLAN ALL OF THAT SAID. FOR THE
PURPOSES OF THIS COMMITTEE AND
FOR PURPOSES OF THE BILL WE
BELIEVE THAT MUCH OF WHAT IS IN
THERE IS ACTUALLY TAKING US AWAY
FROM THE FOCUS.
OF PROTECTING COMMUNITIES AND
FOCUSING ON AREAS WHERE FEET
STOCK REMOVAL WOULD ADVANCE
MANAGEMENT OBJECTIVES FOR THAT
REASON WE SUPPORT THE PROPOSED
AMENDMENTS BY THE COMMITTEE.
AND IN ASK THE COMMITTEE TO DO
AS WELL THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU -- TO HAVE ANYONE ELSE
IN OPPOSITION.
I JUST HAVE A FEW QUESTIONS TO
PEOPLE IN THE INDUSTRY IN TERMS
OF WHEN AND IF -- CENTER YOU CAN
ANSWER THIS BUT I'M TRYING.
TO ASCERTAIN OF WELL WE'VE SEEN
OF UP INITIALLY.
SEVERAL YEARS BACK I REMEMBER.
A NUMBER OF OF DEAD TREES AT THE
HEIGHT OF THE AT THE DROUGHT WE
WERE LOOKING AT ABOUT A HUNDRED
MILLION AND THEN THAT NUMBER
SHUT UP TWO HUNDRED EIGHTEEN
MILLION.
AND I I I THINK THE CURRENT
ESTIMATES ARE ON HUNDRED FORTY
EIGHT MILLION AND WE'RE LOOKING
AT THOSE -- THOSE NUMBERS HAVE
INCREASED OVER THE PAST SIX
YEARS APPROXIMATELY [inaudible]
OF NOT QUANTITY.
HOW MUCH WAS STILL?
AND REMOVED AN INCINERATOR BY
BIOMASS.
YOU HAVE A NUMBER IN TERMS OF
HOW MUCH MATERIAL.
WE HAVE -- FROM MY UNDERSTAND WE
HAVE TWENTY THREE BY A MASS
PLANTS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
HOW MUCH MATERIAL HAS BEEN DEALT
WITH SINCE TWENTY FIFTEEN OR
EVEN ON A PER YEAR BASIS
OPERATING?
AT FULL CAPACITY.
HOW MUCH MATERIAL CAN BE REMOVED
FROM THE ENVIRONMENT?
THESE CURRENT PLANTS A DEALING
ON ASK ABOUT CALIFORNIA BY MASS
ENERGY LINES I DON'T HAVETHE
EXACT NUMBER FOR YOU I'M HAPPY
TO DELIVER IT TO YOU BUT YOU
IT'S INTERESTING THE WHAT YOU'RE
REALLY TRYING TO GET AT IS.
CAN THESE BIOMASS FACILITIES
WHICH ARE.
THERE AREN'T THAT MANY TAKING
FORCE MATERIAL SO THERE'S A
LIMITED NUMBER ABOUT MASS
FACILITIES TAKING FORCE MATERIAL
THEY'RE ALL AND YOU KNOW HOW
MANY ARE TAKING FORCE.
RIGHT SO YOU HAVE THE SEVEN BIO
RAM PLANS AND THEN A SMALL
HANDFUL THAT AREN'T BY AROUND
PLANTS THAT AREN'T ANYWHERE NEAR
YOU KNOW HOW.
MANY OF THOSE ARE SO.
OF THREE FOUR SO WE CAN SAY MAY
BE.
ARE APPROXIMATE ABOUT TEN PLANTS.
YES.
AND APPROXIMATELY HOW MUCH
MATERIAL OR THEY HANDLE IN.
SO FULL BORE TWENTY FOUR SEVEN I TELL YOU THE EXACT NUMBER
WE'RE TALKING HUNDREDS OF THE
TENS OF THOUSANDS OF TONS OF
MATERIAL EVERY YEAR.
AND LARSON H. WOULD THAT BE OF
THE AMOUNT OF TONNAGE THAT'S A
THAT'S CURRENTLY.
IN THE FOREST.
SO THEY'RE JUST DEALING WITH IT
REGIONALLY.
SO THERE THAT THE COMMENT ABOUT
YOU KNOW THIS LIGHTS UP THE
ENTIRE STATE IS -- ONLY TALKING
AS IF I HAD BIOMASS PLANTS
ACROSS THE ENTIRE STATE SO IF I
LOOK AT OUR REGION BERNIE FOREST
POWER FOR EXAMPLE THEY'RE JUST
GOING TO LOOK AT WHAT'S NEEDED
IN THEIR REGION IN THE MATERIAL
THAT'S OUT THERE AND AVAILABLE
IN THAT PARTICULAR REGION.
SO THAT'S WHAT THAT'S WHAT THAT
FACILITY ONCE YOU DO IS TACKLE
WHAT'S WHAT YOU CAN
REALISTICALLY GET AT IN THAT
REGION AND THAT'S AND THAT'S
WHAT WE'RE TALKING OUR REGIONAL
SOLUTIONS NOT NECESSARILY
STATEWIDE SOLUTIONS YOU HAVE.
YOU HAVE INFRASTRUCTURE JUST
LIMITED YOU KNOW AROUND THE
STATE SO YOU'RE YOU'RE BASICALLY
SAYING THESE BIOMASS PLANTS ARE
PROPOSING TO ONLY HANDLE STUFF
IN AND AROUND THEIR VICINITY
NUMBER.
ONE AND THAT THERE AREN'T ENOUGH
[inaudible]
HI.
OF VERY HIGH FIRE PRONE AREAS
AROUND THOSE BIOMASS PLANTS I
THINK WHAT WE'RE SAYING IS IS
THAT THE HIGH HAZARD ZONE AROUND
ANY PARTICULAR.
IN PIECE OF INFRASTRUCTURE WHICH
IS YOUR BIO MASS FACILITY -- IT
DOESN'T COVER EVERY HIGH
PRIORITY AREA.
HI HAZARD ZONES WERE DEDICATED
TO DEAD AND DYING TREES.
NGUYEN WE'RE NOW ASKING IN THIS
BILL TO LOOK AT FIRE --
SEVERITIES.
SO WHAT WE'RE SAYING IS IS THAT
IN THAT REGION FOR EXAMPLE
BERNIE FORCE POWERS SITTING
RIGHT HERE COULD SPEAK TO THAT
MORE SPECIFICALLY -- IN THEIR
REGION THEY HAVE AREAS THAT ARE
HIGH HAZARD ZONE AND AREAS THAT
THEY CAN REASONABLY GET.
TO THAT OUR HIGH FIRED HAZARD
ZONES SO.
WHAT IS TO SAY THAT THIS AREAS
OKAY TO DELIVER MATERIAL TO
THEIR BIOMASS PLANT IN THEIR
REGION?
THAT THIS THIS AREA CANNOT
THAT'S WERE TRYING TO TACKLE
HERE.
ENOUGH AND IS DETERMINES THAT
THE RAIN DETERMINE WHAT IS
ACCESSIBLE WHAT ISN'T.
USUALLY PRICE IS A GOOD --
FACTOR IS THE PROJECT THAT OUT
THERE IS THERE IS THERE FUNDING.
IN THAT PROJECT TO GET THE
MATERIAL OUT.
SO SOMETIMES THE PROJECT WILL
ALLOW YOU TO CUT THE TREES DOWN.
BUT A GOOD PROJECT WILL ALLOW
YOU TO CUT THE TREES DOWN AND
TAKE ALL THAT FOREST WASTE AND
MOVE IT OUT TO A BENEFICIAL
REUSE LIKE BY MASS.
ABOUT IT WE WE WERE MENTIONED
HERE THAT THIS WASN'T A PRICE
BILL THAT WASN'T -- A RATES
BILLS THAT IN FACT RATE PAYERS.
BUT YOU KNOW I I'M JUST WHAT I'M
GETTING AT IS AT THE TIME THAT
THIS WAS APPROVED AND AT THE
TIME THAT WE DID -- APPROVE --
A. B. -- EIGHT FIVE NINE THERE
WAS AN UNDERSTANDING THAT WE
WERE GONNA USE BIOMASS PLANTS
TOO GOOD AT THE HIGHEST THREAT
BECAUSE USING BIOMASS PLANTS TO
HANDLE A HUNDRED AND FIFTY
MILLION.
TREES IS JUST NOT.
OF FUEL MANAGEMENT STRATEGY IS
JUST NOT RIGHT.
I MEAN WHAT ARE WE GETTING OUT
OF HERE IF. FOR TELLING PEOPLE
THAT -- THINGS ARE GOING TO BE
SAFE FROM THE COMMUNITY BECAUSE
BY MASS IS GOING TO HANDLE IT --
I THINK WE'RE COMPLETELY
MISLEADING THE PUBLIC HERE.
AND AND THERE ARE CONSIDERATIONS
WE HAVE TO WEIGH.
ON THE THERE'S COSTS THERE IS.
THERE IS EMISSIONS WHICH IS VERY
IMPORTANT BECAUSE WERE FIGHT
FIGHTING CLIMATE CHANGE.
AND YOU DON'T YOU DON'T -- FIGHT
CLIMATE CHANGE WITH MORE
MISSIONS.
BUT I ALSO UNDERSTAND THESE
FIRES ARE VERY [inaudible]
OF YOU KNOW A FULL OF THE
MISSIONS.
WAY MORE WAY MORE AND AND AND
THE THE OF THOSE EMISSIONS.
OF THE MISSIONS OF BIOMASS PALE
IN COMPARISON BUT WE'RE ALSO
TALKING ABOUT -- WHAT WHAT IS
ESSENTIALLY A FAILED POLICY OF
DEALING WITH THIS THIS THIS --
THIS WASTE.
SO THIS IS WHERE I AM I'M I'M
HOW DO WE TO TELL PEOPLE OKAY
WE'RE GONNA REDUCE THE STANDARD.
SO THAT YOU CAN GET AT THE HIGH
BUT IGNORE THE VERY HIGH.
AND AND YOU KNOW PEOPLE WILL
TAKE WELL THAT'S FOOLISH.
WHY WOULD YOU DO THAT?
AND AND THAT'S WHERE I AM RIGHT
NOW WHY WOULD WE DO THAT.
IF I MIGHT CENTER -- WHAT I
THINK IS HE? ONE OF THE DYNAMICS
AND AND WHAT WHAT I THINK YOU
WOULD BE ABLE TO TELL.
CALIFORNIANS.
IS THAT THE ADMISSIBILITY SHEL
DESIGNATION. FOR THE DEAD AND
DYING TREES.
IT WAS AN AREA IN THIS YEAR AS
WHERE THERE ARE VERY FEW HOMES.
THIS IS AN AREA THAT -- HIGHLY
FORESTED -- A FAIR AMOUNT OF IT
AND DID -- THE US FOREST LANDS --
AND NOT LANDS WHERE WE HAD TO
HOMES AND PEOPLE LIVING -- THE
EXTENSION.
OF THE BIRAM CONTRACTS TO BE
ABLE TO USE MATERIAL THAT'S IN
THE HIGH HAZARD ZONE
[inaudible]
PICKS UP.
THE COMMUNITIES.
WHERE PEOPLE LIVE IN THE WHILE
IN URBAN INTERFACE?
AND SO AND THOSE ARE VERY STRONG
ARGUMENTS SO SO VERY STRONG BUT
THE CURRENT LANGUAGE.
THE ADDRESS WRITTEN AS YOUR
PROPOSED DOES NOT ADDRESS THAT.
AND I'D BE WILLING TO TO AYE
OKAY WITH THIS MY MY LANGUAGE
MAY BE A LITTLE TOO STRICT.
BUT IF WE ARE TALKING ABOUT
GOING AFTER FUEL IN AREAS THAT
ARE HIGH AND DENSELY POPULATED
WAR POPULATED.
VERSES OTHERS THAT ARE NOT I
THINK GIVEN.
THAT WE HAVE.
SEVERE LIMITATIONS AND THIS IS.
AGAIN I HAVE TO STRESS HOW.
I MEAN YOU CAN'T VEN IDENTIFY
WHETHER YOU'VE MADE A DENT.
IN THIS IN THIS PROBLEM.
IT WE'VE ONLY SEEN THE AMOUNT OF
MATERIAL GROW WITH THIS POLICY.
BUT IF YOU THINK YOU COULD MAKE
SOME AREAS SAY FOR USING THIS --
I'LL BE WILLING TO WORK WITH YOU
BUT CURRENTLY THIS THIS LANGUAGE
IS NOT COVER THAT ASPECT OF IT.
AND WHAT I WOULD BE A FEEL
COMFORTABLE DOING AT LEAST
MOVING THE FAULT OF THE BILL
FORWARD WITH THE AMENDMENTS
STRUCK PROPOSED WAS SOME SOME
WILLINGNESS TO WORK WITH THE ONE
AT LEAST CARVING OUT A SOME
EXCEPTIONS SEVERAL.
TARGET.
HI AREAS IN IN RESIDENTIAL AREAS.
IF THAT'S ACCEPTABLE TO YOU.
AND WHILE YOU THINK ABOUT IT
WILL ESTABLISH A QUORUM.
CLERK PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
[inaudible]
WITH SO.
PRESENT WEST OF PRESENT MOORLACH
BRADFORD.
BRADFORD HERE CHIANG DIED.
DIED HERE HERTZBERG HILL MCGUIRE
RUBIO.
RUBIO HERE SKINNER STERN IF
STERN HERE'S DOWN.
DOWN HERE WINNER.
IN HERE.
PUT INTO [inaudible]
OUR WELCOME BACK.
TO SENATOR THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR -- AT GOOD DISCUSSION AND
I AND I UNDERSTAND A LITTLE BIT
BETTER NOW EXACTLY WHAT YOUR
YOUR CONCERNS ARE I THINK
THERE'S SOME -- HERE ARE SOME
GOOD QUESTIONS IN TERMS OF
AMOUNT OF MATERIAL THAT'S BEEN.
OUT BURNED IN THE BIOMASS
FACILITIES WE CAN COME BACK WITH
THAT INFORMATION FOR YOU SO WELL
IT WILL TAKE YOU UP ON YOUR
OFFER -- TO EXCEPT THE
AMENDMENTS THAT YOU PROPOSED AT
THIS TIME AND CONTINUE WORKING
ON IT -- WE THINK THERE'S A WAY
THAT.
WE TO GET -- TO TO YES AND WE
CAN GIVE YOU INFORMATION AND
MAYBE WE CAN FIGURE OUT HOW TO
TIGHTEN IT IN A WAY THAT THAT
WORKS THANK YOU VERY MUCH OKAY --
SO IT'S LIKE IT IT'S IF I COULD
WE'RE GONNA NEED TO ARTICULATE
THE THE AMENDMENTS BECAUSE THE
AMENDMENTS THAT WERE IN THE IN
THE ANALYSIS ARE DIFFERENT THAN
THE END OF IT LEAST AN AMENDMENT
THAT I HE SAW.
ON ANOTHER PIECE OF PAPER SO YES
AND AND WE HAVE THOSE AMENDMENTS
HERE IN WRITING AND I WAS.
GIVEN SOME.
AN AMENDMENT THAT.
THE BY MISTER VERY FROM VERY
HIGH ZONES.
I WILL WE HAVE TO DO IS IS --
PROBABLY DO A LITTLE CARVE OUT --
FOR FOR A HIGH THREAT AREAS IN
RESIDENTIAL AREAS.
AN INMATE AT THE DEVIL'S ALWAYS
IN THE DETAILS.
NOT CRESCENTA CHAIRS -- YOUR
WILLINGNESS TO WORK WITH THE THE
AUTHOR AND THE COOPERATION IS
GOING ON I'M GONNA BRING SUB
THAT DISCOVER Là A LITTLE BIT
OFF TOPIC BUT I JUST KIND OF
WANT TO GET IT IN THE RECORD AND
AND DISCUSSIONS OF IT SINCE NINE
A ONE YEAH THERE WAS A PROVISION.
PUT IN NINE A WIDE THAT WOULD --
REALLY ELIMINATED AGRICULTURAL
WASTE FROM BEING ABLE TO BE USED
IN THESE PLANTS AND THAT ALSO
WASTE FROM WOODY AND WE AWAY
FROM OUR YOUR FOR MORE CITIES
AND COUNTIES IN CERTAIN AREAS
THREATENING.
BIOMASS PLANTS YOUR THROUGHOUT
MY DISTRICT IN OTHER DISTRICTS
AS WLL.
AND I THINK IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT TO HAVE WE ARE WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT CLIMATE CHANGE.
IT JUST [inaudible]
YEAH.
THOSE GOT ALL THAT STUFF INTO
GOING TO THE LANDFILL.
AND RIDING AND EVERYTHING THERE
THE SHORT TERM CLIMATE
POLLUTANTS THAT ARE BURNED ON
EACH AREN'T THAT TWO COURTS BIRD
ALLOWED SITE WHICH IS ARE YOU
MOST DEFINITELY GOTTA COME UP
WITH A SOLUTION TO THIS BECAUSE
IT THIS IS WHAT HAPPENS HERE IS
IT.
THROUGH THE OUR BEST INTENTIONS
WE HAVE BILLS AND SOMEHOW
DIFFERENT LANGUAGE ENDS UP IN
THE BILL THAT -- GOD KNOWS HOW
IT GOT THERE BUT NEVER THE LESS --
I I REALLY APPRECIATE THE
AUTHORS -- YEAH WILLINGNESS TO
WORK HARD ON THIS ISSUE AND I
HOPE THAT.
YOU KNOW I DON'T KNOW IF THIS
COULD BE BROADENED TO YOU --
DEAL WITH THAT ISSUE BUT I WOULD
BE ONE THAT WOULD BE VERY
SUPPORTIVE OF THAT.
SIR BRADFORD.
pTO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR THIS
MEASURE I'VE HAD THE OPPORTUNITY
TO VISIT SEVERAL FILE WICKS
PLANTS.
BIOMASS PLANTS SHOT THROUGHOUT
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA MOST
HOMES SIT IDLE BECAUSE THEY DO
NOT HAVE THE FEEDSTOCK THAT'S
READILY AVAILABLE. TO HELP OUR
LOAD HERE IN CALIFORNIA THIS IS
A COMMONSENSE MEASURE AND THE
CONCERNS ABOUT THAT MISSION FROM
THESE PLANTS HERE THE BRAND NEW
ONE IN WHEAT THAT HAS.
BLESSED IN PRICE SIX YEARS OLD --
WHEN HE STATED OUR PLANTS THEY
BURN WAY MORE TRASH IN DENMARK
AND BIO WASTE?
AND IT'S NO POLLUTION AIR
POLLUTION STANDARDS ARE HIGHER
THAN CALIFORNIA MANY WAYS SO THE
CONTINUE TO SAY THAT THIS IS
GOING TO CREATE MORE GREENHOUSE
GAS EMISSIONS WHEN.
IT PALES IN COMPARISON TO FORCE
FIRE SO -- AND TO SAY THAT IT'S
GONNA COST REPAIRED WELL FIFTEEN
YEARS AGO WHEN WE WERE PROPOSING
WIND AND SOLAR NO ONE WAS
CONCERNED ABOUT RATE PAYERS SO I
THINK THIS IS PART OF THAT
DIVERSIFIED.
OUR ENERGY PORTFOLIO THAT WE'VE
ALL TALKED ABOUT SO I STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS MERGER.
ROHANI ONE ELSE.
OKAY SO WE HAVE ANY JUST WANNA
MAKE ANY CLOSING COMMENTS THE
ONLY CLOSE I'D LIKE TO ADD -- MR
KERRY'S THAT -- I HAD TWO
COUSINS THAT WERE BURNED OUT OF
PARADISE THIS IS REALLY
IMPORTANT TO ME -- BOTH -- I
HAVE TWO COUSINS THAT WERE
FIREFIGHTERS THAT -- THAT THAT
WENT THROUGH A LOT AND SO THE
WHOLE IDEA OF BEING ABLE TO
PROTECT PEOPLE IS REALLY
IMPORTANT TO ME AND I THINK
THAT'S THE REASON THAT WE
PROPOSE THIS BILL.
WILL GO IN AND START DOING SOME
OF THE CLEARING AND AND I I
WANNA -- SECOND WHAT'S BEEN SAID
IN TERMS OF UTILIZING.
THAT AS A OPPORTUNITY TO
GENERATE ENERGY AS OPPOSED TO
BURNING IT OUT IN THE FIELD IS
REALLY IMPORTANT.
A LOT OF WE HAVE A MOTION.
FROM THE MOTION.
WITH A WITH A AMENDMENTS CLICK
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO RULES COMMITTEE.
WESSEL.
I WAS SO I MORE LOT BRADFORD.
BRADFORD I CHIANG DODD.
DODD AYE HERTZBERG HILL MCGUIRE
RUBIO.
RUBIO EYES SKINNER STERN.
STERN ICE.
STONE AYE WIENER.
WIENER AYE.
GET OUT.
OKAY FURTHER WILL HOLD THE ROLE
OF THE PRESS MEMBERS THANK YOU.
CENTER STERN READY YEAH.
AND WHILE WHILE YOU'RE SAID
ENOUGH I HAVE AN ANNOUNCEMENT
FOR PEOPLE IN THE PUBLIC AND FOR
A COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
SB FIVE FOUR EIGHT BY SENATOR
HILL HAS BEEN MOVED TO THE
CONSENT CALENDAR [inaudible]
YEAH
.
WHEN YOU'RE READY SATURDAY THANK
YOU MISTER MEMBERS?
MORNING -- BRINGING TO YOU THIS
MORNING A BILL THAT.
BOTH ENVIRONMENTALLY FOCUS AND
ECONOMICALLY FOCUSED I THINK.
WE'VE BEEN AGGRESSIVE AND BOLD
IN OUR ENERGY EFFICIENCY
STANDARDS AROUND THE STATE IN
OUR BUILDING STANDARDS -- PATH
BREAKING I WOULD SAY.
BUT GOALS ARE NOTHING IF YOU
CAN'T ACHIEVE.
ON THE PROBLEM WE'VE BEEN FACING.
IS THAT IN THE WORLD OF ENERGY
EFFICIENCY.
THE WORK ITSELF TO INSTALL THE
THE LIGHTING CONTROLS AIR
CONDITIONING UNITS HEATING
SYSTEMS.
HAS NOT BEEN UP TO SNUFF ENOUGH
TO ACTUALLY GUARANTEE THAT WE'RE
ACHIEVING EFFICIENCY REDUCTIONS
WE'RE SHOOTING FOR ENTITLED
TWENTY FOUR AND FRANKLY THAT
WERE ACHIEVING OUR SCOPING
PLANNED.
REDUCTIONS THAT A BROADER LEVEL
WHEN IT COMES TO CLIMATE POLICY
WE NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
TONS ARE ACTUALLY DELIVERED.
AND IT.
THAT THESE MEASURES HAVE SOME
TEETH SO THE GOAL HERE TODAY
THOUGH IS TO PROVIDE.
A EXPERIENCE SKILLED WORK FORCE
TO ACTUALLY DO THESE PROJECTS
RIGHT WHEN THEY COME FROM PVC
BASED INCENTIVES THIS IS NOT
INTENDED -- TO PUT IT PUT A FOOT
PRINT ON THE ENTIRE MARKET PLACE
THIS IS ABOUT A CERTAIN CLASS OF
PROJECTS LARGELY COMMERCIAL
PROJECTS OVER FIFTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS IS THE THRESHOLD
IDENTIFIED IN THE BILL.
BUT THE GOAL HERE IS TO TRY TO
GET SKILLED EXPERIENCED WORKERS
DOING.
LARGE SCALE ENERGY EFFICIENCY
PROJECTS THAT WE CAN ACHIEVE.
EFFICIENCY RESULTS WE ONCE THE
SAVINGS RATE PAYERS THAT WE WANT
AND THE GREENHOUSE GAS
REDUCTIONS WE WANT AND BY THE
WAY PROVIDE A PATHWAY. FOR FOLKS
WHO ACTUALLY NEED DURABLE WORK.
FAMILY SUPPORTING WAGES TO
ACTUALLY MAE CALIFORNIA.
MORE LIVABLE PLACE SO WITHOUT A
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOREVER.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS GOT WHICH WE
HAVE THE STATE ASSOCIATION OF
ELECTRICAL WORKERS IN THE
CALIFORNIA COALITION OF UTILITY
EMPLOYEES.
WE A CO SPONSOR THE LEGISLATION
BECAUSE AFTER YEARS OF
PETITIONING THE PVC TO DO WORK
FOR STANDARDS -- THEY JUST HAVE
TURNED A BLIND DIE.
DESPITE THE FOLLOWING STATISTICS --
THE SEEP CPUC ENERGY EFFICIENCY
PROGRAMS ALONE STUDIES HAVE
CONSISTENTLY FOUND.
THAT ACTUAL ENERGY EFFICIENCY
SAVINGS FROM INCENTIVE PROGRAMS.
OR AS LITTLE AS 51%.
OF THE EXPECTED SAVINGS WITH
THEIR EVALUATED POST
INSTALLATION. FOR EXAMPLE POLL
POOR QUALITY INSTALLATION OF
EIGHT TRACK SYSTEMS HAS BEEN
FOUND TO RESULT IN THE 2240%
INCREASE IN ENERGY USE.
THE ENERGY COMMISSION FOUND THAT
UP 285% OF EIGHT TRACK SYSTEMS
ARE INSTALLED INCORRECTLY 85% OR
INSTALLED INCORRECTLY.
AND THEY FOUND IN REGARDS TO
AUTOMATIC DAYLIGHTING CONTROLS.
THAT THOSE FAILED TO PERFORM AS
EXPECTED IN SEVEN OUT OF SEVEN
TESTS.
IN THE OCCUPANCY SENSORS THE
OTHER MAJOR ADVANCED LIGHTING
CONTROL FAILED TO PERFORM AS
EXPECTED IN TWO OUT OF THREE
TESTS.
OTHER STUDIES FOUND THAT TWO
THIRDS OF THE WORKFORCE
PERFORMING THIS WORK HAD NO.
FORMAL TRAINING WHATSOEVER SO
WITH THIS BILL PURPORTS TO DO IS
TO ADD THE SAME SKILLED IN TRADE
WORK FOR STANDARDS THAT WERE
REQUIRED FOR SCHOOL WORK THE
LOCAL GOVERNMENT WORK -- BEST
VALUE WORK IT TO OUR HIGHER
EDUCATION SYSTEMS AND OTHER
PUBLIC WORKS PROJECTS AS WELL AS
REFINERIES [inaudible]
AND THE TO DO SO FOR THOSE OF
YOU WHO DOES THE LABOR COMMITTEE
AND AREN'T FAMILIAR SKILLED AND
TRAINED.
IT REQUIRES THAT BY.
TWENTY TWENTY THE CONTRACTORS
PERFORMING LARGER SCALE
COMMERCIAL SIZE WORK OF FIFTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS OR MORE.
HAVE 60% OF THEIR WORK FORCE
EITHER HAVING GRADUATED FROM A
STATE APPROVED UNION OR NONUNION
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAM.
OR THAT THEIR WORKERS SUGGEST
HAVE N EQUIVALENT WORK
EXPERIENCE MEETING THAT THEY
HAVE WORKED THE SAME AMOUNT OF
HOURS THAT ONE WOULD NEED TO
WORK ON THE JOB IN ORDER TO
GRADUATE FROM A UNION OR
NONUNION PRETTY SHOULD PROGRAM.
THIS IS NOT A UNION OR NONUNION
BILL THIS IS A BILL TRYING TO
ENSURE THAT IF WE'RE GONNA SINK
ALL THIS REPAIR MONEY A BILLION
DOLLARS A YEAR INTO ALL OF THIS
WORK.
THAT IS ACTUALLY PERFORMED BY
EXPERIENCED WORKERS.
SO WE CAN ENSURE THAT WE
ACTUALLY ACHIEVE THE SAVINGS
THAT THE PROGRAMS ARE INTENDED
TO ACHIEVE -- THERE IS WE SAW A
LATE OPPOSITION YESTERDAY'S A
COUPLE RECOMMENDED -- AMENDMENTS
THAT THEY WERE PURSUING.
THE FIRST ONE IS THAT THE AUTHOR --
WORK WITH THEM RELATIVE TO HOW
THE P. YOU SEE CALCULATES THEIR
COST.
RAM ANDERS FOR ENERGY EFFICIENCY
AND WE AGREED AND WILL WORK WITH
THE OPPOSITION ON THAT POINT.
BUT THEN THEY ALSO SUGGESTED WE
SHOULD GIVE EQUIVALENCY.
ARE TWO SKILLED AND TRAINED TO
WORKERS WHO COME FROM A
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES.
AND WHY THAT IS -- A PARTICULAR
PROGRAMS WITHIN DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES AND WHY -- THAT
AMENDMENT ISN'T IS NOT
ACCEPTABLE IN IS NOT NECESSARY.
IS THAT FIRST OF ALL FOR THE
MOST PART WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
TOTALLY UNREGULATED PROGRAMS AND
WHAT AND SO THAT DOESN'T ADDRESS
THE PROBLEM THAT IS AT HAND.
AND SECONDLY THAT LAST CONDITION
ALREADY APPLIES TO THOSE
PROGRAMS IT'S IT YOU CAN COME
FROM PROGRAMS THAT EXIST AND
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES AS
LONG AS YOU JUST HAVE THE SAME
WORK EXPERIENCE THE SAME NUMBER
OF HOURS.
AS SOMEBODY FROM.
THE SHIP PROGRAM SO WITH THAT
WE'D URGE AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING COMMENTS FLOOR ON
BEHALF OF THE WESTERN STATES
COUNCIL SHEET METAL WORKERS ALSO
A CO SPONSOR OF THE BILL ARE WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL FOR
OF PRISONS ARE SCOTTISH
MENTIONED.
I'D LIKE TO POINT OUT A COUPLE
THINGS OF FIRST OF ALL THIS THIS
BILL IS -- ONLY APPLIES TO THE
TOP 1% OF THE ENERGY EFFICIENCY
AND SENATE STATE UTILITIES CARE
OF 99% OF THE PROGRAM TO SMALLER
PROGRAMS.
AREN'T AFFECTED BUT FOR PROGRAMS
WHERE RATE PER TO PUTTING A
SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENT IN TWO
VERY LARGE PROJECTS WE NEED TO
MAKE SURE THOSE PROJECTS.
ARE DONE CORRECTLY AND ARE
ACHIEVING THE SAVINGS.
A MAXIMIZING THE SAVINGS THEY
CAN ACHIEVE ARM.
THERE ARE WESTERN STATES IS ALSO
A MEMBER OF THE COALITION FOR
ENERGY EFFICIENCY WITH THE
COALITION OF ENVIRONMENTAL
EDUCATION EDUCATIONAL LABOR AND
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
ORGANIZATIONS COULD IN BLUE
GREEN ALLIANCE HERE CLUB AND
OTHERS.
THAT HAVE WORKED TOGETHER TO
FIND CONSENSUS SOLUTIONS FOR
FORCE ISSUES FOR ENERGY
EFFICIENCY PROGRAMS THE LONG
SUPPORTED A I WAS GOING TRAINED
WORK FORCE -- REQUIREMENT FOR A
VERY LARGE INCENTIVES AND YOU
KNOW ONE OF THE REASONS FOR
MEMBER WORK WITH OUR
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE PARTNERS
ON THIS IS BECAUSE THEY
RECOGNIZE THAT SKILLED AND
TRAINED WORKFORCE STANDARDS
SUPPORT THIS ADVANCE WORKERS.
BECAUSE THEY INCREASE THE DEMAND
FOR APPRENTICES AND PURCHASE A
PROGRAMS ARE THE PRIMARY PATHWAY
FOR PROVIDING DISADVANTAGED
WORKERS GOOD PAYING CONSTRUCTION
CAREER OPPORTUNITIES -- THAT CAN
SURVIVE CHANGES IN IN THE
INDUSTRY AND AND THEY ALSO
REDUCE WEIGHT TO BENEFIT
INEQUITIES THAT OUR THEIR
WIDESPREAD IN THE CONSTRUCTION
INDUSTRY.
MR PROGRAMS ARE VERY EFFECTIVE
BUT THEY DON'T WORK WITHOUT
APPRENTICESHIP OPENINGS AND
SKILLED AND TRAINED WORKFORCE
REQUIREMENTS MAKE SURE THAT
WE'RE SUPPORTING THE TYPE OF
CONTRACTORS.
THAT ARE PROVIDE ACCESS TO
DISBAND WORKERS SO WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS THANK YOU THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT SURE
MEMBERS THIS IDEAS ON BEHALF OF
THE STATE BUILDING CONSTRUCTION
TRADES COUNCIL ALSO HERE IN
STRONG SUPPORT I JUST WANTED TO
ADD SOMETHING ON THE PRE
APPRENTICESHIP MODEL.
OF THE LEGISLATURE IN THE
GOVERNOR SIGNED LEGISLATION THAT
ACTUALLY ADDRESSESPRE
APPRENTICESHIP TARGETING
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES AND
GROUPS IN PARTNERSHIP WITH
BUILDING TRADES COUNCILS AND
UNIONS.
THAT THERE IS A BETTER
OPPORTUNITY FOR DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES HAVE ACCESS TO ALL
THESE REWARDING JOBS AND CAREERS
IN THE BUILDING AND CONSTRUCTION
TRADES.
BUT ALSO MAKING SURE THAT
THEY'RE EXPOSED TO ALL THE
CAREERS THAT ACTUALLY ARE HIGH
WAGE AND THAT REQUIRE RIGOROUS
TRAINING BECAUSE THIS JOB.
THESE JOBS DO REQUIRE HIGH
SKILLS INTO WHETHER THE USER
STAND STRONG SUPPORT.
US BECAUSE IN OPPOSITION IF WE
CAN -- RATIONS BASE A ONE FOR A
LONG COMMON TO HAVE A SIERRA
CLUB CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT THIS
BILL.
MIKE MONICA WE HAVE THE
CALIFORNIA STATE PATRIOTS
COUNCIL A CO SPONSOR OF THIS
BILL IN SUPPORT.
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS ERRANI
MILA REPRESENTING THE ENERGY
EFFICIENCY AND DEMAND MANAGEMENT
COUNCIL REGRETTABLY OPPOSE
UNLESS AMENDED TODAY -- WE
ACTUALLY DON'T TAKE ISSUE WITH
THE CONCEPT OF SKILLED AND
TRAINED WORK FORCE AT ALL -- WE
TAKE ISSUE.
WITH THE ISSUE THAT MISTER WEST
ALSO ADDRESSED IN HIS TESTIMONY
WHICH IS -- THAT THE P. YOU SEE
HAS A VERY ANTIQUATED DE FACTO
COST CAP.
ON ENERGY EFFICIENCY PROJECTS IN
A WAY THAT IT WORKS BASICALLY IS --
THAT THEY HAVE SET A STANDARD
WHICH DOES NOT COUNT PRIVATE
MONEY OR ACTUALLY COUNTS PRIVATE
MONEY AGAINST THE PROJECT.
ACCOUNTS EIGHT EIGHT COUNTS
PRIVATE MONEY AND PRIVATE
INVESTMENT.
AS A FORM OF REPAIR FUNDS AND IN
DOING THAT BASICALLY THEY HAVE.
CREATED A SYSTEM IN WHICH THESE
PROJECTS LOOK LIKE THEY ARE MORE
EXPENSIVE TO THE RATE PAYER THAN
THEY ACTUALLY ARE AND THAT'S
COUNTED AGAINST THE PROJECT
SECOND THING IS.
THEY NEVER -- US YET COMPARE
ENERGY EFFICIENCY TO THE COST OF
PROCUREMENT WHICH IS ABSOLUTELY
ANTITHETICAL SINCE IN MANY CASES
IT ACTUALLY COMES OUT CHEAPER.
AND THEN THE THIRD THING IS --
THAT THEY ACTUALLY LOOK AT AT DO
A PSYCHOLOGICAL ANALYSIS OF THE
CUSTOMER TO DETERMINE.
WHETHER THE CUSTOMER WOULD HAVE
MADE THE IMPROVEMENT ANYWAY AND
THEY USE THAT TO DISCOUNT THE
ACTUAL VALUE OF THE PROJECT.
SO ALL THREE OF THOSE THINGS
SORT OF ANTIQUATED WAY OF
LOOKING AT ENERGY EFFICIENCY NOT
ALLOWING IT TO BE COMPETITIVE
WITH OTHER RESOURCES.
IS HOLDING ENERGY EFFICIENCY
BACK MAKING IT DIFFICULT TO PAY
THE WAGES THAT ENERGY EFFICIENCY
PROJECTS WANT TO PAY.
AND SO WE ARE SIMPLY ASKING --
AS TIME MOVES ON TO WORK ON THIS
ISSUE -- WITH THE AUTHOR AND
SPONSORS WE HAD WE'VE HAD SOME
VERY GOOD CONVERSATIONS ABOUT
THIS SB THREE FIFTY AS YOU ALL
KNOW.
ANTICIPATED THE DOUBLING OF
ENERGY EFFICIENCY GOALS ENERGY
EFFICIENCY COMPANY SINCE THEN
HAVE LEFT THE STATE AND SO HAS
SOME OF THE WORK FORCE THAT WE
RELY ON AS A RESULT OF THESE
ANTIQUATED P. YOU SEE PROCESSES.
AND SO WE WANT TO THANK THE
AUTHOR AND THE SPONSORS FOR
HAVING THESE VERY PRODUCTIVE
CONVERSATIONS WE'RE GOING TO
CONTINUE -- AND WE APPRECIATE
THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE IN OPPOSITION.
WE HAVE SOME CLEAR FINE CHAIN OF
AMENDMENTS THAT HAVE BEEN
PROPOSED YES SO THANK YOU I I
WANT TO ACCEPT THE AMENDMENTS.
AND I ALSO I MEANT TO CLARIFY IN
MY OPENING ALTHOUGH I THINK YOU
HEARD IT FROM -- OUR SUPPORTERS
THAT -- THE CONCERNS RAISED
ABOUT THAT CURRENT METHODOLOGY
AT THE PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION I BIND TO BE
COMPELLING AND MEAN.
THE GOAL SHOULD BE. TO GET MORE
THROUGHPUT AND EFFICIENCY
PROJECTS WRIT LARGE IN THE
STATES OF THAT'S HOLDING US BACK
FROM ACTUALLY GETTING.
GROWING THE PIE IN MEETING THAT
DOUBLING TARGET I'M OPEN TO THAT
TOO SO IF THAT'S ALRIGHT WITH
YOU SEE EXCEPT THAT BUT ALSO
COMMITTED TO WORKING WITH.
OUR FOLKS IN THE EFFICIENCY
DEMAND COUNCIL -- YET COMPARED
ACOSTA PROCUREMENT EXCLUDING
PARTISAN ACROSS IN THESE
CONCEPTS THEY RAISE THEIR NEW SO
I'M JUST TRYING TO GET MY HEAD
AROUND IT BUT I'M OPEN.
TO WHAT WHY.
WIFE OF FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLAR
THRESHOLD IS SAD.
IS THAT JUST RANDOM ISN'T BASED
ON SOMETHING IN PARTICULAR THAT
CAME OUT OF A ROSS SAYS WITH
THAT LARGER COALITION THAT WAS
REFERENCE TO CHAIRMAN WITH THE
THE VARIOUS ENVIRONMENTAL GROUPS
AND SOME THEM -- ECONOMIC
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE GROUPS.
AND SAVE ME SOME KIND OF AN EGG
ANECDOTAL EXAMPLE OF OF A OF A
PROJECT AND WHAT ARE YOUR USUAL
WHO WAITED WHERE IT USUALLY
COSTS WOULD YOU GET FOR FIFTY
THOUSAND YET WHAT ARE WE LOOKING
AT HERE FIFTY FIFTY THOUSAND
ZERO GRAHAM THAT IS.
SUPPORTED BY THE THE P. UC'S
PROGRAM.
SO.
CHECK THIS PLACE.
AS SOON AS CHAIRMAN -- TWO GOOD
EXAMPLES OF THAT WOULD BE FOR
INSTANCE A MEDIUM SIZE MAYBE
THREE STORY COMMERCIAL BUILDING
THAT NEEDS.
NEW HEATING AND AIR CONDITIONING
SYSTEM AND A NEW COOLING TOWER
WHICH ARE TWO HUGE ENERGY USERS.
I KNOW THE ADEQUATE AND OUTDATED.
CERTAINLY THE FIFTY THOUSAND ONE
PAY FOR ALL THAT WORK BUT IT
WOULD IT BE YOU KNOW -- A REBATE
THAT WOULD ALLOW A PROJECT
HONORED WILL MOVE FORWARD ON
DOING THAT TYPE OF WORK.
OR IT MIGHT BE GOING INTO A
MEDIUM SIZE COMMERCIAL BUILDING
AND REPLACE REPLACING ALL OF THE
LIGHTING FIXTURES. TO HIGH
EFFICIENCY LIGHT FIXTURES AS
WELL AS IN INSTALLING --
ADVANCED LIGHTING SO THE REBATE
WOULD BE APPLIED TO THE FIFTY
THOUSAND COST OR WHAT WHAT WHAT
WOULD BE THE THE REBATE ITSELF
THE THRESHOLD IS FIFTY THOUSAND
DOLLAR.
SUCH A FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLAR
REBATE OR MORE YEAH OKAY SO IT
APPLIES TO THE PRINT NOT THE
PROJECT COSTS BUT THE REBATE
COST [inaudible]
OKAY.
OKAY ANY ANYTHING ELSE ARTS
CENTER WIENER.
THANK YOU UNDER SECURE I'M
SUPPORTIVE OF THIS BILL.
THANK YOU FOR BEING FORWARD A
ONE THING I KNOW I REYES IF YOU
IN WITH THIS TO WATCH AS WELL AS
THE WANTING TO BE CLEAR THAT
THIS BILL IS NOT.
INTENDED TO APPLY TO DVRS SOLAR.
I KNOW THERE ARE PROBABLY OTHER
DISCUSSIONS HAPPENING AROUND
THOSE ISSUES NOT TO SEPARATE.
A DISCUSSION I KNOW YOU MIGHT
THINK YOU WANT TO BE A MOMENT TO
TALK CLARIFIES OUT BUT I THINK
THERE ARE SOME CONTINUING
CONCERNS AROUND SOLAR THERMAL.
AND SO -- I JUST WANNA MAKE SURE
THAT THOSE CONVERSATIONS WILL
CONTINUE TO TO MAKE SURE THAT
THE LANGUAGE.
CLEARLY REFLECTS WHAT I KNOW
YOUR INTENT IS SO CAN YOU CALL
YEAH NO THANK YOU -- YEAH THE
GOAL WAS TO TRY TO REFINE THE
DEFINITION TO SOMEWHERE -- MORE
NEAR WE'RE TRYING TO FOCUS ON
ENERGY EFFICIENCY HERE THAT'S
THE SCOPE -- SO IF YOU HAVE ANY
FURTHER REFINEMENTS NEEDED.
THE COMMITTEE STAFF DID A PRETTY
GOOD JOB TODAY BUT YEAH THIS IS
THIS IS ABOUT.
THE SORT OF EFFICIENCY THERE'S
THERE'S A SPECIFIC KIND OF
PRETTY GOOD JOB YOU WANT US TO A
BETTER JOB.
YEAH WE KNOW BETTER JOB.
YOUR BILL.
A GREAT JOB.
YEAH I'LL JUST JUST CLOSE MY
MOUTH AND SAY.
YES.
ABOUT THAT FOR YOU BUT THEY'LL
BE CONTINUING AS DIALOGUE YES
THANK YOU I'M SAYING.
THANK YOU SENATOR.
CENTER BRADFORD THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND NO DOUBT WE WE WANT TO
SKILLED WORKFORCE ARE IN PLACE.
TO DO THIS ENERGY EFFICIENCY
WORK BUT I GUESS MY CHALLENGES
WHEN YOU'RE CONSTANTLY REFERRING
TO DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES THE
ONLY REASON THEIR DISADVANTAGES
THAT THERE NEVER GIVEN THE
OPPORTUNITY IT'S NOT THERE.
THAT THEY LACK THE SKILLS SAID
IN MANY CASES THERE THIS NEVER
GIVEN OPPORTUNITY SO THAT'S WHY
THESE CONTINUE TO STATE.
DISADVANTAGE WHAT WILL BE THE
OUT REACH TO REALLY TAP INTO
THIS WORKFORCE BECAUSE WE
CONSCIOUSLY TALK ABOUT.
DISADVANTAGED PEOPLE OF COLOR
BUT EVERY TIME WHEN I LOOK AT
THESE PROJECTS.
NOT A MORE ON THE WORK SITE HOW
DO WEEKS REALLY EXPANDED IN AND
HIT THE TARGET.
CENTER BRADFORD SCOTT WHAT
SHOULD WE HAVE TO KILL THREE
COLORS UTILITY EMPLOYEES AND THE
I. B. W. UP FIRST AND FOREMOST I
WANT TO CLARIFY THAT NOTHING IN
THIS BILL AFFECTS THE SET ASIDE
MANDATE I THINK THAT YOU ARE THE
AUTHOR OF THAT REQUIRES A
CERTAIN PERCENTAGE OF ALL.
CONTRACTS TO GO TO MINORITY AND
WOMEN AND DISABLED VETERAN OWNED
BUSINESSES -- IN ADDITION THAT
THE LEGISLATION THAT.
MY COLLEAGUES HIS IDEAS
REFERENCE REGARDING -- PROVIDING
THE RESOURCES TO EXPAND AND
CREATE MORE PRE APPRENTICESHIP
PROGRAMS.
IS REALLY KICKING IN YOU KNOW
ONE OF THE LARGEST ONES AT ELLIE
TRADE TECH.
WHERE -- THEY'RE DOING EXTRA
GREAT WORK THERE -- WE'RE HOPING
TO EXPAND THAT BELIEVE ME WE
NEED MORE WORKERS -- NOT.
WE HAVE ADEQUATE WORK FORCES
TODAY BUT WE DO HAVE AN AGING
WORKFORCE IN SO THOSE PRE
PENSION PROGRAMS ARE REALLY
GOING TO BE WHAT FEEDS ARE
PRETTY SHOULD PROGRAMS.
GOING FORWARD.
THE FOR AS FOR BECAUSE ARE
SKILLED AND TRAINED LANGUAGE
ALLOWS AN EQUIVALENCY.
FOR WORKERS ARE HAVING GONE
THROUGH AN APPRENTICESHIP
PROGRAM BUT HAVE JUST BEEN HIRED
BY BY A CONTRACTORS.
AS LONG AS THEY HAVE THE
PREREQUISITE NUMBER OF HOURS --
THAT'S REALLY WITH A BIG BURDEN
IS BECAUSE THE THE UNION SECTORS
INVESTING TENS OF MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS IN TRAINING AND WE ARE
RECRUITING FROM DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES.
IT IS THE VAST MAJORITY OF
CONTRACTORS WHO ARE NONUNION --
WHO ARE INVESTING A DIME IN
TRAINING PROGRAMS AND -- I THINK
THAT'S AN AREA WHERE THE
LEGISLATURE COULD TO FOCUS SOME
SOME ATTENTION AND DO SOME GOOD.
RIGHT CAN I JUST ASK WHO ARE YOU
SEE THE GREATEST DIVERSITY.
AND NON UNION [inaudible]
CONTRACTORS.
IT IT IT DEPENDS REGION FROM
REGION.
AND I CAN I JUST ADD ON THOUGH I
DON'T WANT TO OVER PROMISE WITH
THIS BILL SENATOR BRADFORD I DO
NOT THINK THIS BILL IS GOING TO
SOLVE THE GAP.
I I I THINK I THINK YOU'RE
POINTING IN YOUR LEADERSHIP FOR
US ALL BACK IN THE ASSEMBLY AND
GET THE P. YOU SEE ON TRACK AND
GENERAL CONTRACTING IS STILL.
CREATING MEANINGFUL PASS OUT OF
POVERTY TO THIS DAY BUT THIS.
THIS PROGRAM ON ITS OWN I DON'T
THINK IS ENOUGH TO DRIVE I THINK
WE GOT TO DO MORE.
THINGS LIKE THERE'S A THERE'S
TWENTY FIVE MILLION IN G. G. OR
F. PROPOSES YOU'RE ON WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT GOING TO
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES AND
PUSHING SOMEBODY'S
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS WORKING
WITH FOLKS LIKE ARCHITRAVE TECH
LA. FOR THE FORMERLY
INCARCERATED.
I THINK WE HAVE TO DO MORE I
GUESS IS MY POINT SO ANYA THANK
YOU YEAH.
ANYONE ELSE A SUNROOF JUST A
QUICK COMMNT THANK YOU THANK
YOU FOR YOUR INFORMATION I'M
JUST NOT QUITE SURE YOU OF
ANSWERED MISTER BRADFORD
QUESTION IN TERMS OF THE OUT
REACH I KNOW.
ELLIE TRACK TRADE TACK YOUR
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS.
BUT THESE ARE PEOPLE THAT ARE
THERE WHAT ARE YOU DOING FURTHER
TO GO DEEPER AND I'M THINKING
MORE IN ARE YOU REACHING OUT TO
YOU KNOW HIGH SCHOOLS SCHOOLS.
I'M NOT SURE YOU'VE ANSWERED
THAT QUESTION SPECIFICALLY CAN
YOU SHARE A LITTLE BIT SURE --
WE DO DO THAT SO THE WAY THAT A
PRETTY SHIP WORKS.
IS -- THERE IS A VERY SMALL PART
OF MONEY THAT THE STATE PROVIDES
CALLED MONTOYA DOLLARS
[inaudible]
AND FOR EVERY DOLLAR OF MINE
TôI AT FUNDS THAT ARE SPENT ON
A PRETTY SHIP IN PRE OF
FRIENDSHIP.
OUR UNION EMPLOYERS AND OUR
UNION SPEND ABOUT TEN DOLLARS
AND SO WOULD LITERALLY EACH AND
EVERY YEAR.
WE'RE SPENDING TENS OF MILLIONS
OF DOLLARS THAT RATHER THAN
GOING ON TO THE PAYCHECK.
OF THE WORKERS.
GETS CONTRIBUTED TO THE POT TO
GO AND GROW THE WORK FORCE AND
SO WE'RE GOING WE HAVE OUTREACH
PROGRAMS. TO EX MILITARY WE HAVE
AGGRESSIVE CALLED HELMETS TO
HARD HATS -- WE HAVE -- A GOOD
PROGRAM THAT THE SENATOR
REFERENCED GOING AFTER -- THE
FORMERLY INCARCERATED.
WE'RE GOING INTO -- HIGH SCHOOLS
I MEAN WE ARE EXPANDING RIGHT
NOW IN MY TWENTY SOME YEARS WE
HAVE NEVER HAD MORE APPRENTICES
IN THE PIPELINE AND WE DO TODAY.
AND WE CERTAINLY HAVE NEVER HAD
AS MANY FROM DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES NOT ONLY BECAUSE OF
THE PROGRAMS THAT WERE FUNDING
BUT BECAUSE OF YOU KNOW THE
PROLIFERATION OF PROJECT LABOR
AGREEMENTS AND WHAT WE'VE DONE
IN MOST MAJOR PRO PROJECT LABOR
AGREEMENTS FOR INSTANCE THE
PROJECT STABILIZATION AGREEMENT
WITH.
LA UST.
HAS A REQUIREMENTS THAT WE GO
OUT AND HIRE -- FOLKS CERTAIN
PERCENTAGE OF FOLKS FROM
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES SO --
WE ARE AGGRESSIVELY PURSUING
THAT.
THANK YOU THAT ANSWERS THE
QUESTION PRECIADO.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU OF CENTER STONE YEAH
THANK YOU MISTER WHICH OF MISTER
MISTER AND MISTER WHICH THE H.
FACT INSTALLATIONS ARE PRETTY
IMPORTANT IN MY DISTRICT FOR
GETS TO BE A HUNDRED TWENTY TWO
DEGREES.
IN THE SUMMERTIME -- STATEWIDE
WHAT IS WHAT WOULD YOU SAY WITH
THE PRINT THE PERCENTAGE OF H.
BACK INSTALLERS WOULD BE PEOPLE
THAT UP AND THROUGH AN APPROVED
PRINCIPAUX GRAHAM THROUGH --
YOUR YOUR YOUR SOURCES.
WELL BECAUSE AT THE CENTER I
THANK YOU THAT THE A PRETTY SURE
PROGRAMS OF COURSE OF COURSE ARE.
COVERED -- UNION AND NONUNION
EMPLOYERS SO CURRENTLY IN
CALIFORNIA BETWEEN THE SHEET
METAL WORKERS AND THE UNITED
CESSATION OF PLUMBERS AND FIGHT
AND PIPEFITTERS WHO BOTH DO THAT
WORK.
WE PROBABLYHAVE AROUND --
400-004-0000 CURRENT -- WORKERS
I WOULD SAY WITH THE NON UNION
YOU COULD PROBABLY ADD ANOTHER --
YEAH YOU COULD PROBABLY ADD
ANOTHER.
AT LEAST THAT NUMBER I MEAN
PROBABLY IT YEAHTHEY'RE STILL
THE WORK FIRST MAYBE FIFTEEN OR
TWENTY THOUSAND SO BETWEEN.
THE UNION IN THE NON YOU
WORKFORCE I WOULD SAY IT'S
UPWARDS OF SIXTY THOUSAND AND
THEN.
THE SECONDARY -- PROVISION
REQUIREMENT IS IS IF YOU HAVEN'T
GONE THROUGH AN APPRENTICESHIP
PROGRAM OR AREN'T CURRENTLY IN
INFORMATION PROGRAM.
IF YOU HAVE THE EQUIVALENT
WORKERS -- THE EQUIVALENT
WORKING HOURS IN THE INDUSTRY.
ABOUT TWO THOUSAND I BELIEVE IS
THE THAT WOULD BE A THE
APPROPRIATE FIGURE.
THEN THERE'S YOU KNOW TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF MORE OF COURSE AND
I WOULD SAY THAT YOU KNOW
PROBABLY MORE THAN HALF OF THE
FOLKS WORKING IN THE INDUSTRY
RIGHT NOW.
PROBABLY HAVE THAT HAVE THAT TO
WORKING CLOSELY SEE FOR THE
BRITISH OKAY SO YOU SAY ABOUT
50%.
I AM NOT DE.
I'M I'M GUESSING AT MY
EXPERIENCE UNFORTUNATELY THERE
ARE CONTRACTORS COULD BE HERE.
TO THE HEARING BUT THEY COULD
BARELY SPEAK TO WORK MORE
CLOSELY BUT CERTAINLY.
YOU KNOW ALL OF THE HEATING AND
AIR CONDITIONING CONTRACTORS IN
YOUR AREA THAT BEEN AROUND FOR A
VERY LONG TIME PROBABLY MANY OF
THEM NON UNION.
THEIR WORKFORCE HOW TRANSITORY
IS IT THEY PROBABLY HAVE A WORK
FORCE TO BE SUS REQUIRE BRIDGES
BY THE ON JOB ON THE JOB
EXPERIENCE OKAY BUT YOU SAY
ABOUT 50% PROBABLY ARE OF THE
POPULATION THAT YOU REPRESENT.
WE OWE IT I KNOW I SAID AS I
SAID WE HAVE PROBABLY ABOUT.
SIXTY THOUSAND IN THE WORK FORCE
OKAY.
OUT OF HOW MANY IN THE WORK
FORCE.
WOULD YOU SAY I AND I HAVE THIS
FOR YEARS AND FOR ME SENATOR BUT
40% 50%.
HI I WOULD BE MORE THAN WILLING
TO GO ON A LIMB HERE AND SAY
THAT.
THAT AT LEAST 40% OF THE TOTAL
WORKFORCE DOING HEATING AND AIR
CONDITIONING SYSTEMS HAS EITHER
GRADUATED FROM STATE APPROVED A
PRESSURE PROGRAM OR HAS THE
EQUIVALENT HOURS WHICH WOULD BE.
IN THE YOU KNOW OVER A HUNDRED
AND FIFTY THOUSAND EMPLOYEES
EVERYTHING OKAY I APPRECIATE ALL
THE SO THAT'S A REFLECTION NOT
ONLYON OUR YOUR FRIENDSHIP
PROGRAMS AND PEOPLE THAT ARE
SUPPOSEDLY TRAINED -- SO SO WE
HAVE A PROBLEM NOT ONLY.
IN -- NONUNION APPRENTICESHIPS
BUT IN IN IN FRIENDSHIPS AS WELL --
WHICH IS BECAUSE AT ILLUSTRATIVE
OF WHAT.
THAT DOESN'T ACTUALLY CRACKED
OKAY BECAUSE WHAT WE WE WE ALSO
ALL OF OUR CONTRACTORS HAVE
INDIVIDUALS THAT HAVE BEEN
CERTIFIED BY NATIONAL.
THIRD PARTY ACCREDITATION AS
ACCEPTS ACCEPTANCE TESTERS.
ACCEPTANCE ACCEPTANCE TESTERS
ARE THE PEOPLE WHO GO IN
COMMISSION BUILDINGS AFTER AN H.
FAX SYSTEM IS INSTALLED.
SO FOR THE SEGMENT OF THE H. FAQ
SYSTEMS THAT WE INSTALL.
THE 85% FIGURE IS THE THE NUMBER
OF EIGHT TRACK SYSTEMS INSTALLED
THROUGH ONE OF THESE REBATE
PROGRAMS NOT OUT THERE IN
GENERAL SO NO THAT THAT THAT'S
IT IS NOT CORRECT APPRECIATE
THAT.
SO MUCH MY CONCERN IS THAT I
HAVE -- MANY RURAL AREAS --
DESERT CENTER -- POLITE AREA --
WHERE?
ARE YOU DON'T THEY MAY NOT BE
ABLE TO GET SOMEBODY HAS BEEN
APPROVED OR A STATE
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAM -- AND
I'M CONCERNED THAT THAT'S KIND
OF A LITMUS TEST OF OF THIS BILL
IS THAT IF YOU ARE.
GRADUATING FROM STATE APPROVED
PRINTER PROGRAM NOT WHETHER NOT
YOUR SKILLED AND TRAINED IN
ORDER TO DO THIS WORK.
MY MISSING SOMETHING YOU ARE
SENATOR BUT THINGS BUT AGAIN
I'LL JUST REPEAT WHAT I SAID
EARLIER WHICH IS THERE'S TWO
PATHWAYS HERE TO BEING SKILLED
AND TRAINED. ONE IS THAT YOU'VE
GRADUATED FROM A STATE APPROVED
UNION OR NONUNION FRIENDSHIP
PROGRAM AND THERE'S A NON UNION
A PRINTER PROGRAM SERVING YOUR
DISTRICT RIGHT.
OR YOU'RE A JOURNEY PERSON THAT
HAS THE EQUIVALENT WORK
EXPERIENCE SO IN LESS EVERY AGE
FAQ INSTALLER YOUR DISTRICT JUST
MOVED TO CALIFORNIA OR JUST
PICKED UP THE TRADE.
THAT WOULD BE THE CASE IN YOUR
DISTRICT.
THANKS FOR VERIFICATION.
CENTER CAN I JUST ADD CLOSING
COMMENTS YA ALL WRAPPED IN MY
CLOTHES -- ICING IS A REALLY
HEALTHY DISCUSSION BETWEEN SAYS
RUBIO BRADFORD AND STONE TODAY
JUST IN TERMS OF LET'S GET A
SENSE OF THE BROADER JOBS
PICTURE HERE.
WE'RE GOING AFTER ONE SLICE OF
PROJECT BUT THERE IS A BROADER
NEED TO LOOK AT THE ENERGY
EFFICIENCY JOBS SPACE IF YOU'RE
HAVING GROW THAT POT WE WE
ACTUALLY DON'T WANT TO REDUCE
THE NUMBER JUDGE IF YOU WANT.
TO INCREASE AND WE'RE GOING TO
HAVE TO THE ROUGH DATA FOR YOU
OUT OF IT AB. TWO THOUSAND
SIXTEEN REPORT FOR ADVANCED
ENERGY ECONOMY IS THAT ABOUT
THREE HUNDRED TWENTY ONE
THOUSAND WORKERS IN TWENTY
FIFTEEN WORKED IN BUILDING
ENERGY EFFICIENCY WRIT LARGE.
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT A SLICE OF
VERY HIGHLY SKILLED AND TRAINED
AND EXPERIENCED WORKERS DOING.
SIRIUS LARGE SCALE PROJECTS THAT
THAT PERSON Sí
YOUR HOUSE OR YOUR YOU KNOW YOUR
FAMILY'S HOUSE -- IS NOT REALLY
THE TARGET THIS BILL BUT I THINK.
THERE IS A BROADER NEED TO LOOK
AT THAT AND AND TO REALLY GET
THE NUMBERS RIGHT AND FIGURE OUT
WHAT OUTCOMES WE WANT TO SEE AND
IF WE'RE GETTING THE FOLKS.
IN RURAL COMMUNITIES IN
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES THOSE
WHO NEED A SECOND SHOT AT LIFE
SO I'M COMMITTED TO WORKING ON
THAT WITH YOU AS WE AS WE MOVE
THIS BILL LONG ANSWER TO GETTING
THE DATA RIGHT SO WE CAN SCOPE
THE PROBLEM -- BUT I I DO
APPRECIATE THAT AND WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
THANK FOR THE DISCUSSION.
VERY WELL OF TO HAVE A MOTION.
WE HAVE A MOTION WITH AMENDMENTS.
AND YOU ACCEPT ALL THE
AMENDMENTS.
A CLERK PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
DO YOU PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS WEST SO.
HI WITH SO I MOORLACH
[inaudible]
BRADFORD.
KING.
CHIANG AYE DODD AYE DODD AYE
HERTZBERG.
HERTZBERG AYE HILL HILL AYE
MCGUIRE MCGUIRE AYE RUBIO.
RUBIO AYE SKINNER STERN STERN
ICE DOWN.
NO WIENER WIENER I THE WE'LL
KEEP THE ROLE OF REPS OF MEMBERS
CAN I GET A MOTION ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR -- ITEM NUMBER
FIVE SB FIVE LORI.
CLICK PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
SB FIVE FORTY EIGHT HILL DO PASS
TO APPROPRIATIONS WESTELL BY WAS
SO I MOORLACH.
BRADFORD.
CHIANG CHING AYE DODD.
DIED AYE HERTZBERG HERTZBERG AYE
HILL HILL AYE MCGUIRE.
MCGUIRE AYE RUBIO.
RUBIO AYE SKINNER STERN STERN
AYE STONE STONE AYE WIENER.
WIENER AYE.
OKAY.
BELIEVE IT OF PERHAPSOF MEMBERS
CENTER REQUIRE FOR YOU READY --
FOR SB.
SIX SEVENTY YEAH YEAH YEAH YEAH.
I THINK.
THE EMAIL [inaudible]
AVOID [inaudible]
THAT'S BRAND.
SECURE YOU GOOD.
TO WHEN YOU'RE READY FIVE THANK
YOU SO MUCH.
I WANNA MEMBERS ARE TAKE MOMENT
SAY THANK YOU TO THE CHAIR.
THANK YOU TO HIS COMMITTEE TEAM
FOR THEIR WORK ON SB -- SIX
SEVENTY OVER THESE PAST MANY
MONTHS.
UNDER TO BE ABLE TO PRESENT SB.
SIX SEVENTY RELATED TO NINE ONE
ONE EMERGENCY LEARNING
CAPABILITY.
AN OUTAGE NOTIFICATIONS I WOULD
LIKE TO THANK AGAIN THE CHAIR
FOR THE WORK I AND I ALSO WOULD
LIKE TO THANK SENATORS DODD AND
STERN FOR THEIR PARTNERSHIP.
UNDER PERCENT PARTNERSHIP ON
THIS LEGISLATION.
THE NIGHT OF OCTOBER EIGHTH A
CHANGE THE LIVES OF TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF CALIFORNIANS
FOREVER.
WHETHER YOU'RE ONE OF THE ONE
HUNDRED THOUSAND EVACUATED IN
THE NORTH BAY AREA. ONE OF THE
SIX THOUSAND WHO LOST THEIR HOME.
ONE OF THE THOUSANDS WHO FLED IN
THE MIDDLE A NIGHT THROUGH THE
FLAMES.
BUT ONE OF THE DOZENS WHO LOST A
LOVED ONE DUE TO THE FIRE.
WE BELIEVE THAT THERE LAW SHOULD
NOT KNOWING BAY.
IMAGINE BEING IN A LIFE
THREATENING EMERGENY PICKING UP
YOUR PHONE TO CALL 911- AND
HAVING NO SERVICE OR DIAL TONE.
OR BEING DEAD ASLEEP IN NEVER
RECEIVING EMERGENCY ALERT. TO
LET YOU KNOW THAT FLAMES HER
CLOAK CLOSING IN IN.
THERE ABOUT TO ENGULF YOUR HOME.
UNFORTUNATELY THOUSANDS OF
CALIFORNIANS ARE FACED WITH THIS
REALITY SEVERAL TIMES A YEAR NOW.
AND THESE REAL WORLD SCENARIOS
ARE INCREASING TO THE SIZE AND
SCOPE OF CALIFORNIA'S WILDFIRES.
AN EMERGENCY OR CATASTROPHIC
SITUATION LACK OF ACCESS TO
EMERGENCY SERVICES ARE PUBLIC
ALERTS AND WARNINGS PUT LIVES AT
RISK.
SB SIX SEVENTY IS A SIMPLE STEP
TO MITIGATE THE RISKS DURING
TIMES OF A TOTAL CRISIS -- IN
PHONE OUTAGES BY REQUIRING
TELECOMMUNICATIONS PROVIDERS TO
REPORT NINE ONE ONE SERVICE
OUTAGES OR OUTAGES AFFECTING
EMERGENCY ALERT IN MORNING
TECHNOLOGIES TO THE CALIFORNIA
OFFICE OF EMERGENCY SERVICES IN
REAL TIME.
IT SEEMS LIKE IT SHOULD ALREADY
BE HAPPENING.
BUT IT'S NOT.
IT'S COMMONSENSE APPROACH WILL
ENSURE COORDINATION BETWEEN
STATE AND LOCAL EMERGENCY
OFFICIALS AND TELECOMMUNICATION
COMPANIES.
SB SIX SEVENTY WILL PROVIDE
EMERGENCY OFFICIALS WITH REAL
TIME DATA IN THE CRUCIAL
INFORMATION THEY NEED TO KEEP
OUR COMMUNITY SAFE.
SO THERE ARE SOME FEDERAL
THRESHOLDS THE FEDERAL
TELECOMMUNICATION -- COMMISSION
FCC ONLY REQUIRES REPORTING
OUTAGES THAT LAST THIRTY MINUTES
AND HAVE THE POTENTIAL TO IMPACT
NINE HUNDRED THOUSAND USER
MINUTES.
UNDER THIS THRESHOLD IT WOULD
TAKE TEN THOUSAND PEOPLE HAVE
BEEN AN OUTAGE THAT LAST NINETY
MINUTES.
BEFORE THE THRESHOLD TO
REPORTING TO THE F. C. C.'S HIT
AND THEN PROVIDERS ARE GIVEN
ANOTHER HUNDRED TWENTY MINUTES
TO NOTIFY THE FCC.
AND WHILE THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
UTILITIES COMMISSION AND FCC
HAVE A SHARED RESPONSIBILITY TO
OVERSEE ALL COMPONENTS AND I'M
WILLING SERVICE.
OUTAGE REPORTING TO THE VIEW
SEIZE PROVIDED HOURS.
IF NOT SOMETIMES DAYS AFTER THE
ACTUAL.
OUTAGE OCCURS NOT REAL TIME.
I'D LIKE TO GIVE YOU TWO
EXAMPLES OF TWO MASSIVE FIRES IN
THE CHALLENGES THAT WE FACE.
DURING THE CAMPFIRE.
WHICH BEGAN AROUND SIX THIRTY
THREE AM.
ON NOVEMBER EIGHTH.
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN THE CPC
RECEIVE THEIR NOTIFICATION OF
THE OUTAGE.
THAT IMPACTED THE SIGNIFICANT
PORTION OF BUTTE COUNTY.
FROM THE FCC.
OVER FIVE HOURS LATER.
AT TWELVE OH ONE PM.
AFTER THOUSANDS OF HOMES HAVE
BEEN DESTROYED.
IN LIVES LOST.
THE TUBS FIRE IN SANTA ROSA
BEGAN AT APPROXIMATELY NINE
FORTY THREE PM ON OCTOBER EIGHTH.
TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN IN THE
CPC RECEIVE THEIR FIRST
CERTIFICATION FROM THE FCC OVER
SIX HOURS LATER AT FOUR TWELVE
AM.
THE NEXT MORNING.
THOUSANDS OF HOMES IN THAT TIME
HAD BEEN DESTROYED.
AND BY THAT TIME THE TUBS FIRE
HAD BURNED INTO CENTRAL ST SANTA
ROSA.
IN TAKING DOWN ALL OF COFFEE
PARK.
THE CALIFORNIA OFFICE EMERGENCY
SERVICES NEVER RECEIVED FORMAL
NOTIFICATION IN THE SENTENCES.
IS REPORTING CAME TOO LATE.
AND IT'S SIMPLY UNACCEPTABLE.
CURRENTLY ONE TELECOMMUNICATIONS
SERVICES GO DOWN AFFECTING NINE
ONE ONE SERVICE OR THE ABILITY
FOR EMERGENCY SERVICES. TO SEND
EMERGENCY ALERTS
TELECOMMUNICATION COMPANIES ARE
NOT REQUIRED TO REPORT REAL TIME
INFORMATION ABOUT THE LOCATION
OF THE OUTAGE HOW MANY
INDIVIDUALS ARE AFFECTED.
IN WHEN THE ESTIMATED TIME FOR
REPAIR IS.
CALIFORNIANS CANNOT AFFORD TO BE
WITHOUT THE MOST UP TO DATE
INFORMATION DURING TIMES OF
DISASTER.
FAILURE TO REPORT OUTAGES
AFFECTING NINE ONE ONE SERVICE
OR EMERGENCY ALERTING
CAPABILITIES CAN WREAK HAVOC ON
COMMUNITIES AND PUTS THE PUBLIC
SAFETY AT RISK WHAT YOU HEAR
FROM BOTH THE SHERIFF.
AS WELL AS THE FIRE CHIEF TODAY.
SB SIX SEVENTY WOULD REQUIRE
PROVIDERS OF TELECOMMUNICATIONS
SERVICES TO PROVIDE NOTIFICATION
THE CAL O. YES WHETHER THERE IS
A NINE ONE ONE SERVICE OUTAGE OR
ANY OUTAGE AFFECTING EMERGENCY
WARNING CAPABILITIES WITHIN
SIXTY MINUTES.
OF THE OUTAGE OCCURRING CALORIE
S. WITHIN BE RESPONSIBLE FOR
NOTIFYING THE AFFECTED LOCAL
COUNTY -- YES WHICH WOULD THEN
WORK WITH OBVIOUSLY THE SHERIFF
IN THE LOCAL FIRE DEPARTMENT IS
TO ENSURE ALL THE NECESSARY
EMERGENCY OFFICIALS ARE GIVEN
THE INFORMATION THEY NEED TO
KEEP RESIDENTS SAFE.
TELECOMMUNICATION PROVIDERS
WOULD BE REQUIRED TO NOTIFY
CALLOW YES WITHIN SIXTY MINUTES
OF THE FOLLOWING TYPES OF
OUTAGES WITH SOME COMMONSENSE
DATA POINTS.
A DESCRIPTION OF THE ESTIMATED
AREA AFFECTED THE APPROXIMATE
NUMBER OF CUSTOMERS AFFECTED THE
ESTIMATED TIME TO RESTORE THE
OUTAGE AND A CONTACT PERSON THAT
CAO YES CAN REACH.
UP FOR FURTHER UPDATES VERY
SIMILAR TO WHAT WE ALREADY SEE
WITH POWER OUTAGES IN THE STATE.
ONCE THE NINE ONE ONE EMERGENCY
ALERTING CAPABILITY OURS HAS
BEEN RESTORED THE
TELECOMMUNICATION PROVIDER WOULD
ALSO NEED TO NOTIFY CAL WE ASK
THAT RESTORATION OF SERVICE HAS
OCCURRED -- I WILL END IT RIGHT
HERE MISTER CHAIR I SIX SEVENTY
ONE SURE THAT OUR STATE LOCAL
EMERGENCY OFFICIALS RESPOND HERS
AT THE CRUCIAL INFORMATION THEY
NEED TO RESPOND WHEN THOSE EXTRA
MINUTES.
COULD SAVE LIVES MISTER CHAIR
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME TODAY --
WE HAVE TODAY TONY GOZER FIRE
CHIEF OF THE CITY SANTA ROSA.
CITY SANTA ROSA THE CALIFORNIA
FIRE CHIEF AND PROFESSIONAL
FIREFIGHTERS SUPPORT THIS BILL
WE ALSO MARK ESSEX SHARE FOR
CINEMA COUNTY THE CALIFORNIA
SHERIFF'S ASSOCIATION ALSO
SUPPORT THIS LEGISLATION.
IF IT'S POSSIBLE TO ADD ANYTHING
TO THAT PLEASE PROCEED HEY THERE
YOU GO [inaudible]
YEAH.
BOB GOOD MORNING CHURN MEMBERS
MY NAME IS TONY GUYS FROM THE
FIRE CHIEF FOR THE CITY OF SANTA
ROSA.
THE RECENT FIRES IN CINEMA NAPA
INVENTOR COUNTY AND I SAY RECENT
AS TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN SINCE
THEN THERE'S BEEN A A NUMBER OF
OTHER CATASTROPHIC.
CATASTROPHIC FIRES.
HAVEN'T BEEN AMONG AMONG THE
MOST DESTRUCTIVE IN STATE
HISTORY.
THE DISASTERS HAVE SHOWN THAT
THE A MERCY TELECOMMUNICATIONS
SYSTEMS NEEDS TO BE IMPROVED.
BOTH FOR RESIDENTS AND FIRST
RESPONDERS.
ALL OF YOU KNOW THAT THE WHEN
THE TUBS FIRE STARTED AT NINE
FORTY THREE ON SUNDAY NIGHT IT
TOOK FOUR HOURS.
I BURN TWELVE MILES TO GET TO
THE CITY OF SANTA ROSA AND
ENTERED THE CITY AT ONE O'CLOCK
IN THE MORNING -- AND I'LL TELL
YOU THAT SANTA ROSA ON ITS OWN
FRONT -- BETWEEN SIX PM AND
TWELVE AM THAT NIGHT HAD TEN
REPORTED STRUCTURE FIRE SOME
TWENTY REPORTER VEGETATION FIRES.
BEFORE THE TUBS FIRE EVEN CAME
INTO THE CITY.
SO WE AS THE FIRE SERVICE WAS
ALREADY VERY BUSY -- DEALING
WITH OUR OWN LOCAL EMERGENCIES.
REMINDED TWENTY FOUR PEOPLE DIED
DURING THIS TIME -- BY SIX
O'CLOCK IN THE MORNING MOST OF
THE DAMAGE HAD BEEN DONE -- YOU
KNOW THE CITY OF SANTA ROSA LOST
OVER THREE THOUSAND HOMES -- THE
CITY AND THE COUNTY TOGETHER
LOST OVER SIX THOUSAND HOMES.
AND THAT'S JUST THE FIRES IN
CINEMA COUNTY WE ALSO THE ALICE
PEAK FIRE THAT LOST MEMBER OF
HOMES AS WELL AS LIVES WE HAD TO
REDWOOD.
VALLEY FIRE THAT ALSO LOS NUMBER
OF HOMES AND LIVES.
A SOURCE NOT JUST IN ON THE
COUNTY THIS IS REALLY A
STATEWIDE ISSUE AND WHAT THE WAY
THE FIRES ARE BURNING IN TODAY'S
WORLD.
THEY'RE BURNING MUCH FASTER MUCH
MORE TENSE AND MOVING OUT WITH
MUCH MORE PURPOSE.
SB SIX SEVENTY WOULD REQUIRE
PROVIDERS OF TELECOMMUNICATIONS
SERVICES TO NOTIFY CAL -- YES
WHENEVER THERE'S A NINE ONE ONE
SERVICE OUTAGE OR ANY OUTAGE
AFFECTING EMERGENCY WARNING
CAPABILITIES WITHIN SIXTY
MINUTES.
OF THE OUTAGE -- CALLOUS WITH
THEN LET LOCAL MERCY PERSONAL
KNOW THAT THESE CHANGES WILL
ENSURE ALL THE NECESSARY --
MERCY OFFICIALS ARE GETTING THE
INFORMATION THEY NEED TO KEEP
RESIDENTS SAFE.
I WILL TELL YOU THAT IS MUCH
BETTER THAN WHAT WE'RE DOING
TODAY.
I DON'T THINK IT IS SOON ENOUGH
I THINK SIXTY MINUTES IS A
LITTLE BIT LONG -- BUT WHAT I
WILL TELL YOU IS THIS GIVES US
THE ABILITY TO HAVE THE
SITUATIONAL AWARENESS WERE
ALREADY IN CONTACT WITH -- YES
WHEN FIRES ARE STARTING TO BREAK
OUT BUT WE DON'T HAVE ANY
INFORMATION IN TERMS OF
TELECOMMUNICATIONS -- THE NIGHT
OF OCTOBER EIGHTH SEVENTY TOWERS
WERE LOST WITHIN THE INITIAL
HOURS OF THE EVENT.
WHICH REALLY IMPACTED OUR
ABILITY TO NOTIFY THE PEOPLE
THAT WE'RE SUPPOSED TO PROTECT --
ONCE ONCE THOSE TOWERS ARE DOWN --
IN ALL BETS ARE OFF MOST PEOPLE
RUN AROUND AT THAT POINT.
IN WHAT THIS WILL DO THE WHAT
THIS BILL DOES LET THAT LET US
KNOW THAT THERE IS A FAST MOVING
FIRE THAT THERE IS A POTENTIAL
ISSUE AND WE HAVE TO NOTIFY MUCH
SOONER.
MUCH SOONER THAN LATER.
SB SIX SEVENTY WILL ENSURE THAT
OUR STATE AND LOCAL MERCY
OFFICIALS AND AND FIRST
RESPONDERS HAVE THE CRUCIAL
INFORMATION THEY NEED TO RESPOND.
TO THOSE EXTRA MINUTES THAT
COULD SAVE LIVES.
THIS BILL IS ONE OF THE MOST
IMPORTANT MAJORS THAT COME
BEFORE THE LEFT THI LEGISLATION --
SESSION IT IS.
PAST SUPPORT OF CAL CHIEFS -- MY
MAYOR -- UNFORTUNATELY FOR US WE
COULDN'T GET IT THROUGH THE CITY
PROCESS AND CONCEPT -- SUPPORT
THIS 1100% AND MAYOR TOM WHAT
HOME IS IN HIS FULL SUPPORT OF
THIS -- AND IN I'M PROUD TO BE
HERE TO TO SPEAK THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AND ANYONE ELSE
[inaudible]
MORE.
GOOD MORNING CHAIR REMEMBERS MY
NAME IS MARK ESSICK.
AND THE SHERIFF THE CINEMA
COUNTY.
ALSO A LIFELONG CALIFORNIA
RESIDENT.
AND MY FAMILY'S BEEN IN CINEMA
COUNTY SINCE.
EIGHTEEN NINETY I'M HERE TODAY
BECAUSE I'M CONCERNED.
AND I'M HERE AT THE REQUEST
SENATE REQUIRED TO TALK ABOUT MY
CONCERNS.
IN RECENT YEARS WE'VE WITNESSED
SOME OF THE MOST DESTRUCTIVE
FIRES IN OUR STATE'S HISTORY.
IN CINEMA COUNTY ALONE THE FIRES
OF TWENTY SEVENTEEN BUT THE LOSS
OF TWENTY FOUR LIFE IN THE
DESTRUCTION OF MORE THAN SIX
THOUSAND HOUSING UNITS AND OTHER
STRUCTURES.
AS YOU'VE ALREADY HEARD.
IT'S UNTHINKABLE DISASTER WAS
MET HEAD ON BY THOUSANDS OF WELL
TRAINED PUBLIC SAFETY
PROFESSIONALS WHO SELF SACRIFICE
PREVENTED GREATER DAMAGE.
AND EVEN MORE LOSS OF LIFE.
BUT TRAINING WILL ONLY TAKE A SO
FAR WE MUST BE BACKED UP BY THE
TOOLS AND TECHNOLOGY TO MEET THE
NEEDS OF THESE MORE COMPLEX
CHALLENGES.
THESE DISASTERS PROVED THAT ARE
EMERGENCY TECHNOLOGY SYSTEM IS
IN DIRE NEED.
OF AN UPGRADE FOR RESIDENTS AND
FIRST RESPONDERS ALIKE.
SB SIX SEVENTY IS A SIMPLE STEP
IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION.
THIS LEGISLATION WOULD REQUIRE
TELECOMMUNICATIONS PROVIDERS TO
NOTIFY CALLOW YES WHENEVER THERE
IS A NINE ONE ONE SERVICE OUTAGE
OR ANY OUTAGE AFFECTING
EMERGENCY WARNING CAPABILITIES.
WITHIN SIXTY MINUTES THE OUTAGE.
THIS NOTIFICATION THE STATE
OFFICE OF EMERGENCY SERVICES
WOULD ALLOW IMMEDIATE
NOTIFICATION OF FIRST RESPONDERS
LOCALLY.
BY ALLOWING OUR EMERGENCY
OPERATIONS TO KICK IN.
AND BE PREPARED. FOR FIRST
RESPONDERS MINUTES EQUAL LIVES.
AS YOU'VE HEARD THE TUBS FIRE
RIPPED AT ABOUT NINE FORTY FIVE
PM.
BY MIDNIGHT TWO HOURS LATER THE
FLAMES ROUTE PASSING CARS AND
EVACUEES.
WE HAVE FLAMES MOVING FASTER
THAN WE CAN EVACUATE PEOPLE.
ROADS WERE BLOCKED RESIDENTS
FOUGHT.
FIRST RESPONDERS TRIED TO GET IN
AND SAVE LIVES.
DURING THE FIRES AT MONTHS SOME
SEVENTY COMMUNICATION TOWERS
WERE LOST AND WITHIN THE
CRITICAL LIFELINE FOR RESIDENTS
AND EMERGENCY SERVICE PERSONNEL.
THE LOSS OF THOSE TOWERS
PREVENTED OUR ABILITY TO SEND
OUT ALERT AND WARNING.
IT TOOK MORE THAN SIX HOURS. FOR
THE CPUC TO RECEIVE NOTIFICATION
FROM THE FCC THAT THESE TOWERS
WERE DOWN.
AND THAT NINE ONE ONE SERVICE
OUTAGES WERE OCCURRING.
THE OFFICE OF EMERGENCY SERVICES
WAS NEVER FORMALLY NOTED
NOTIFIED AT ALL.
IN THE CAMP FIRE MOST RECENTLY
IN BUTTE COUNTY.
THAT TIME LAPSE WAS
APPROXIMATELY FIVE HOURS AGAIN
PREVENTING.
CRITICAL NOTIFICATIONS.
THIS IS SIMPLY UNACCEPTABLE.
AS WERE SPYING DISASTER WE NEED
TO ALL HAVE THE SITUATIONAL
AWARENESS AND DATA THAT WE CAN
GET AS FIRST RESPONDERS.
WE NEED TO KNOW THE
TELECOMMUNICATION PROVIDERS WILL
BE OUR PARTNERS EMERGENCY
RESPONSE.
I BELIEVE THAT SIX SB SIX
SEVENTY IS A SOLID FIRST STEP
TOWARD ENSURING THAT OUR STATE
AND LOCAL EMERGENCY OFFICIALS
HAVE CRITICAL INFORMATION NEEDED
TO RESPOND WHEN THOSE EXTRA
MINUTES COULD SAVE LIVES THANK
VERY MUCH ANYONE ELSE AND
SPEAKING SUPPORT.
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS PAUL YOU'RE ON
WE HAVE THE BOARDS TO RISE TO
NAPA AND SONOMA COUNTIES IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
GOOD MORNING MR TERM MEMBERS WHO
SHALL MUCH LOWER ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA STATE SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATION SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING KIANA ROSS ON
BEHALF OF THE CITY OF SANTA ROSA
MAYOR CONTROLLED HOME IS THE
FIRE CHIEF HAD NOTED.
MORNING THREE ZERO COUNTY
REPRESENTS CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
YES SANDERS REPRESENTING THE
PUBLIC ADVOCATE'S OFFICE
FORMALLY REFER TO AS THE OFFICE
THREE FOR ADVOATES IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF SB SIX SEVENTY THANK
YOU.
GOOD MORNING A RUBBER DO HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA CITIES
ALSO IN SUPPORT.
MORNING MR MEMBERS BERNIE A
ROSTER WITH CALIFORNIA CABLE AND
TELECOMMUNICATIONS ASSOCIATION
HERE IN SUPPORT OF AMENDED SO
WE'VE BEEN WORKING WITH MR
REQUIRE -- AND I THINK WE'RE
MAKING SOME VERY POSITIVE
PROGRESS THANK YOU.
YOUR MEMBERS STEVE KERR ALSO
PROCEED TI A WHERE THE WIRELESS
INDUSTRY TRADE ASSOCIATION WE'RE
ALSO WORKING WITH MISTER MCGUIRE --
AND WORKING WITH -- YES AT THE
SAME TIME THERE ARE MEMORANDUMS
OF UNDERSTANDING THAT ARE THAT
ARE BEING WORKED ON TO MAKE SURE
WE BUILD IN THE UP APPROPRIATE
FLEXIBILITY.
AT THE LOOK AT THIS GOING
FORWARD AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH YOU.
BILL DIVIDE WITH EIGHTEEN ANTI
WE SUPPORT IF AMENDED THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE OUT THERE ANYONE
OPPOSITION.
ALL SPEAKERS IF YOU WANNA GET A
WORD ON THIS BILL PLEASE COME TO
THE MIKE.
GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
JAMES JACK ON BEHALF OF CAL TELL --
WE HAVE A LETTER OF OPPOSITION
TO THE BILL AS WRITTEN -- WHICH
WOULD APPEAR TO REQUIRE
NOTIFICATION FOR FOR EVERY
SINGLE OUTAGE HOWEVER -- MUCH AS
MY COLLEAGUES HAVE SAID WE HAVE
HAD A VERY -- PRODUCTIVE
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE AUTHORS
OFFICE AND CONTINUE TO WORK.
TOWARDS -- BUT WE HOPE TO BE
APPROPRIATE THRESHOLD TO TRIGGER
THE NOTIFICATION -- AND LOOK
FORWARD -- TO REMOVING OUR
OPPOSITION IS THE FILM'S FORWARD
THANK YOU OKAY VERY WELL --
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE ANYONE
CENTER HILL THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND AND THE SENATE RECORD
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PERSISTENCE.
ON THIS ISSUE -- I KNOW WHAT
PERSISTENCE FEELS LIKE -- AND I
I JUST THINK THAT IT'S IT'S IT'S
TIMELY AND IT NEEDS TO BE DONE I
AGREE AND OURS TOO LONG.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THIS CHALLENGES
YOU FACED LAST YEAR THE YEAR
BEFORE -- AND IT'S IT'S THAT'S
UNACCEPTABLE AS WELL AND
INTERESTINGLY IN MY DISTRICT
WHERE YOU WOULDN'T THINK ON THE
COAST WE'VE HAD.
WE HAVE AN INFORMANT IN A COUPLE
WEEKS BECAUSE COMMUNICATION IS
DOWN THERE'S ONE LINK THERE'S NO
REDUNDANCY IT TAKES ONE LITTLE
TREE. TO FALL.
IN THEIR OUT OF THE INTERNET AND
EVERYTHING FOR HOURS AND HOURS
AND HOURS OF WE NEED TO DO IT
AND THE SOONER THE BETTER THANK
YOU CENTER BUT I'LL BE HAPPY TO
MOVE THE BILL.
AS AS SOON HE SAID THAT ALL OF
MY CENTERS TO SPEAK CENTER STONE
I THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN I
ALSO WANT TO PLUG MY MY FRIEND
MR CENTER RIGHT FOR BRINGING
THIS FORWARD -- HAD TO DIVERSITY
FIRES LAST YEAR IN MY DISTRICT
ONE IS A HOLY FIRE ONCE THE
CRANSTON FIRE -- THE THE THE
WONDER BRINGS -- FEAR IN MY MIND
WHAT IS THE CRANSTON FIRE
BECAUSE THE YOUR GRAPHICS IS
VERY SIMILAR TO PARADISE THERE'S
ONLY ONE WAY AND ONE WAY OUT IN
AMOUNT COMMUNITY THAT HOUSE
THREE OR FOUR THOUSAND PEOPLE.
IT WAS START BY STARTED BY
ARSONISTS WAS STARTED AT THE
BOTTOM OF THE HILL HAD IT BEEN
STARTED TO THE TOP OF A HILL OR
OF A POWER LINE WOULD COME DOWN.
AND STARTED A FIRE THERE -- WE
WOULD WIPE OUT ALL COMMUNICATION
AND WE WOULD TALK ABOUT THE
INCINERATION OF THOUSANDS OF
PEOPLE NOT A FEW HUNDRED WHICH
WE BELIEVE ME WERE VERY
SYMPATHETIC AND EMPATHETIC AND
FOR THE LAWSUIT YOU SEEN IN YOUR
DISTRICT AND INDICATOR
LEGISLATION IS GOING TO HELP
PREVENT THESE.
HORRIBLE DISASTERS AND AND LOSS
OF LIFE -- FROM HAPPENING IN THE
FUTURE SO -- THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR THREE TO FOUR AND THEN --
YOUR WORK WITH THE THE
OPPOSITION IS THE BILL MOVES
THROUGH AND SO AND AT THE PROPER
TIME AND I COULD BE ADDED AS A
CO AUTHOR THANK YOU SO MUCH
THANK YOU [inaudible]
VERY WELL.
CENTER RUBIO.
IS REALLY QUICKLY THANK YOU
THANK YOU FOR PUTTING THIS
TOGETHER.
WELLFIRST I WANT TO THANK US
SENATOR STERN AS WELL HE WAS
GRACIOUS ENOUGH TO SET UP A TOUR
OF WITH THE WHEELS THE FIRES AND
WE WERE ABLE. TO GO OUT INTO THE
COMMUNITY REALLY SPEAK TO THE
FAMILIES IMPACTED BY LACK OF
COMMUNICATION CELL THIS IS
REALLY IMPORTANT THAT WHEN YOU
SPEAK TO THOSE.
ARE DIRECTLY AFFECTED BY BY A
NOT YOU NOT HAVING COMMUNICATION
IT BECOMES EVEN MORE HER MY
POINT FOR ME PRESS SEEN AND DONE
SO THANK YOU JUST FOR BRINGING
IT UP SO JUST WANNA.
STATE THAT HE SAID.
WHEN YOU SEE ONE QUICK THING
SORRY I'LL BE QUICK?
I FEEL LIKE THIS YEAR. ONE IS A
IS.
A CHAMPION YEAR AFTER YEAR.
LET'S CHARGE AND GET SOME THINGS
DONE THIS BILL IS IMPORTANT IT
IS NOT THE WHOLE SOLUTION.
THERE'S SO MUCH ELSE THIS SINGLE
POINT OF FAILURE THROUGHOUT OUR
TELECOMMUNICATION YSTEM THAT'S
GOING TO CONTINUE PUT OURSELVES
AT RISK THIS NOTIFICATION I HOPE
IS.
ONE THEY'VE BEEN ONE ASPECT OF
THIS RISK IN THE **** BUT WE'VE
GOT A LOT MORE TO DO IN TERMS OF
MAKING OUR COMMUNICATION SYSTEM
MORE RESILIENT HAVING PROPER
BACKUP POWER IT'S SYSTEMS.
HAVING REDUNDANCIES SO THANK YOU
FOR THAT AND LOOK FOR TO WORK
WITH IN THE FUTURE THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR FOR INDULGING ME.
THANK YOU WITH THAT NEEDED TO BE
SAID THANK YOU -- CENTER MORE
LUXURY.
THANK YOU RICHARD I THANK YOU
CENTER REQUIRE I JUST HAVE ONE
QUICK QUESTION IN THE THE STAFF
REPORT THERE WAS AN OUTAGE IN
MENDOCINO COUNTY IN.
TWENTY FOURTEEN AND IT STATES
THAT ACCORDING TO A LOCAL
INCIDENT REPORT.
TELEPHONE INTERNET CELLULAR AND
NINE ONE ONE SERVICES WENT DOWN
FOR THOUSANDS OF RESIDENTS.
AND INTERNET SERVICE WAS.
OUT ALMOST COMPLETELY ALONG THE
FORTY MILE QUARTER FOR
APPROXIMATELY FORTY FIVE HOURS A
NIGHT AND AND THE BILL REQUIRES.
THAT THE OUTAGE NOTIFICATION.
MUST BE SUBMITTED BY ELECTRONIC
MAIL SO I'M JUST TRYING.
TO WE ASK.
YOU KNOW.
WHAT HAPPENS IF THE WHOLE THING
IS OUT AND YOU?
IT THEN YOU JUST SHOW THAT YOU
HAVE BEEN TEND TO USE SCENTED
NUMBERS BOUNCE BACK OR NO IT
WOULD GO DIRECTLY TO THE EARLY
WARNING CENTER -- AT THE OFFICE
EMERGENCY SERVICES THEY WOULD
ALSO THERE WOULD BE PHONE
CONTACT -- BUT THE REASON WHY WE
WANT TO BE OR TO PUT IT IN
WRITING THAT WOULD GO FROM THE
TELECOM COMPANY WHERE THEY'RE
LOCATED -- TO THE EARLY WARNING
CENTER THERE AT THE OFFICE WERE
TO SERVICES BECAUSE IT IS IT HAS
ALL THE INFORMATION THEY NEED
ALL IN ONE LOCATION BUT HAPPY TO
GET A LOOK AT THAT ON IN REGARDS
TO THE ISSUE OF EMAIL.
AS WELL WE'RE RELYING MAYBE ON
SATELLITE VERSES.
OTHER LANGUAGES YEAH I MEAN I
WILL SAY THAT IS A VERY UNIQUE
ISSUE I BELIEVE THE TWO THOUSAND
FOURTEEN MISTER DEVINE IS
UNFORTUNATELY VERY WELL WHERE
THAT ONE IS WHAT I WEAR A BOX
TRUCK.
I TOOK -- A WHOLE FIBER CABLING
DRUG ALONG ONE A ONE FOR ABOUT
TWO MILES -- IN THE LET -- THAT
TOOK EVERYBODY DOWN -- FROM
NORTHERN MENACING KNOW ALL THE
WAY UP ALMOST THE OREGON BORDER.
SO IT ACTUALLY WAS A LITTLE
LONGER THAN THAT AND IT WAS A
REAL SHOW I WILL SAY -- BUT I
WILL FOLLOW UP ON THAT ISSUE AS
WELL.
THE COMMISSION -- NEVER GO.
YES.
CENTER DOT YEAH JUST JUST
BRIEFLY -- I APPRECIATE THE
COMMENTS THANK YOU -- FOR THIS
GREAT BILL WAS AND WHY BUT I TH.
I THINK YOU SENATOR STERN SAYS
THAT -- YEAH THIS IS THIS IS ONE
TOOL THE TOOL BAG TO DO A BETTER
JOB.
THANK YOU KNOW CLEARLY EVEN IN.
YEAH WE HAD THE THE QUICKLY WE
FORGET THE FIRE THE STAR THE
PARCC FIRE.
THE CAME FROM NAPA ALL THE WAY
BLUE RIGHT IN THIS AT ALL ABOUT
[inaudible]
IT HAD.
YOUR PARTY FABULOUS FROM THE
CINEMA.
YEP.
ALL IT IS.
I GUESS THE COUNTY FIRE.
SPECIAL DISTRICT HE'S ACTUALLY
JUST RIGHT.
THEY DIDN'T EVEN KNOW WAS COMING.
THEY HAD NO IDEA WAS COMING SO
THIS IS NOT EVEN YELLED AT
IMPACTING -- OUR CITIZENS BUT
IT'S ALSO IMPACTING YOUR
ESSENTIAL SERVICES AND SO
COMMUNICATION THE OTHER LEVELS.
YEAH THAT NINE ONE ONE FEE I I
YOU KNOW THE NEW INTER.
ACTIVITY BETWEEN DEPARTMENTS AND
EVERYTHING IT'S JUST ABSOLUTELY
CRITICAL THAT WE DO A BETTER JOB
SO THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SENATOR THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PARTNERSHIP COMMERCENTRE
STERN.
WE HAVE A MOTION [inaudible]
SENATOR DODD -- DID YOU WANNA
MAKE ANY CLOSING COMMENTS.
JUST WANT TO SAY THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR INTO THE TWENTY
THANK YOU TO THE CENTER NIELSEN%
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GALLAGHER COULD
NOT BE HERE TODAY WHO ARE ALSO
CO AUTHOR SOMEONE TO MAKE SURE
EVERY.
MENTION IT THANK MISTER TERRY
THE CLERK PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
TO PASS TO GOVERNMENTAL
ORGANIZATION COMMITTEE LESS SELF.
I WAS SO I AM MORE LOT.
MORE LIKE AYE BRADFORD CHIANG.
CHING AYE DODD.
DODD AYE HERTZBERG.
HILL AYE HILL AYE MCGUIRE.
HI MCGUIRE AYE RUBIO.
REVIEW AYE SKINNER STERN.
STERN AYE STONE STONE AYE WIENER.
WIENER AYE.
THAT'S A WE HAVE WE HAVE IT'S
PAST BUT WILL HOLD THE ROLE OPEN.
CENTER MCGUIRE.
SO.
I LIKE ENTERTAIN A MOTION TO
ADJOURN.
BLOOD DEAL WITH -- FILE ITEM
NUMBER ONE SB FOUR FIFTY SEVEN
THE WORLD FAMOUS SENATOR HUESO
IS HERE TO PRESENT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THIS IS --
PRETTY COMMONSENSE MEASURE IT'S
OF THE FOUR FIFTY SEVEN HE IS A
BILL TO SUPPORT THE STATE'S
BURGEONING INNOVATIONS WITH BY A
METHANE -- IT'S ONE OF THE
STATE'S EFFORTS TO REDUCE.
OUR CARMEN CARBON EMISSIONS.
I AS A MEMBERS WILL RECALL I
AUTHORED AS P. FORTY FORTY LAST
YEAR WHICH REQUIRES A CPUC. TO
ESTABLISH PROCUREMENT
REQUIREMENTS FOR BY A METHANE
THIS BILL IS COMPLEMENTARY.
BUT OF A MODEST EFFORT -- IN
THAT REGARD IT WILL EXTEND THE
SUNSET THAT DATE BY FIVE YEARS
OF OF AS BEFORE -- FIVE SEVEN
FROM -- TWENTY TWENTY ONE TO
TWENTY TWENTY SIX IT'S AN
EXISTING INCENTIVE PROGRAM TO
SUCCESSFUL SUCCESSFULLY OPERATE
BY OMITTING PROJECTS.
THAT -- INTERCONNECT THE GAS
UTILITY PIPELINE SYSTEM
BASICALLY WORK WORK WERE
INJECTING.
VERY CLEAN RENEWABLE BIO METHANE
INTO OUR EXISTING.
UP.
A GAS PIPELINES UNDER THIS ODD A
SPECIFIC PROGRAM THIS EXTENDS --
THE THE THE TIMELINE.
I'D IT EXTENDS THE SUNSET DATE
THOSE STEP BY STATUTE -- SO --
HICKS -- IT'LL ALLOW FOR THOSE
IMPROVEMENTS TAKE PLACE MOVING
FORWARD.
AND I ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT FOR
THIS WE HAVE SOME.
TEST TEST PEOPLE HERE TESTIFIED
ON THIS NINA COMPORT IN
PARTICULAR.
GOOD MORNING AT MEMBERS NEEDING
SUPPORT THE COALITION FOR
RENEWABLE NATURAL GAS WE
REPRESENT OVER A HUNDRED AND
EIGHTY MEMBERS IN EVERY SECTOR
OF THE INDUSTRY AND WE REALLY
PROPONENTS OF AB NINETEEN
HUNDRED GADO THE ORIGINAL
LEGISLATION THAT ENABLED -- THE
CREATION OF THIS PROGRAM AND
ALSO THE SPONSORS OF SB.
FOURTEEN FORTY IN ITS MOST
RECENT SCOPING PLAN THE
CALIFORNIA AIR RESOURCES BOARD
RECOMMENDS REPLACING FALSE
APPEALS WITH RENEWABLE NATURAL
GAS REDUCING DEMAND FOR NATURAL
GAS AND MOVING TOWARDS RENEWABLE
NATURAL GAS WILL HELP CALIFORNIA.
ACHIEVE ITS TWENTY THIRTY
CLIMATE TARGET HOWEVER THE HIGH
COST OF PIPELINE INTERCONNECTION
HAS LED TO EVEN CALIFORNIA BASED
COMPANIES CONSTRUCTING THE
MAJORITY OF OUR ENERGY
PRODUCTION FACILITIES OUTSIDE OF
CALIFORNIA.
IRONICALLY MOST OF THE RG
PRODUCED IS THEN SENT BACK TO
CALIFORNIA -- FOR COMPLIANCE
WITH VARIOUS CALIFORNIA PROGRAMS
AND SO AT THIS PROGRAM HAS
REALLY HELPED TO ENHANCE THE
COMPETITIVENESS OF IN STATE --
PARK PROJECTS AND WE ADD THESE
YESTERDAY AFTER I VOTE TODAY
THANK YOU.
MISTER FOUR ARE THERE ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING CAM CARMICHAEL AND
HAVE A SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA GAS
COMPANY TO ADDITIONAL POINTS --
THEIR RESOURCES BORDERS ON
RECORD IN THIS BUILDING A COUPLE
TIMES OVER THE LAST YEAR SAYING
THAT IF WE DON'T HAVE A STRATEGY
FOR NOBLE GAS.
WE DON'T HAVE A CLIMATE STRATEGY
FOR CALIFORNIA I WANT TO
EMPHASIZE THAT POINT BECAUSE OF
THE POTENCY OF METHANE.
WE NEED TO HAVE.
BILLS LIKE THIS TO ENABLE US TO
ADDRESS OR NOBLE GAS.
AND USE IT IN CALIFORNIA --
SECOND POINT IS THE SUM OF THE
COMMENT LETTERS FOCUSED ON
DAIRIES.
YES THAT'S A BIG.
PART OF THIS CHALLENGE AN
OPPORTUNITY.
SHE'S ME BUT I ALSO WANT TO
REMIND THE COMMITTEE THAT THERE
ARE CAL RECYCLE ORGANIC
DIVERSION.
TARGETS COMING ONLINE OVER THE
NEXT SEVERAL YEARS THAT ARE
GOING TO REQUIRE -- THAT WE DO
DEAL WITH ORGANIC WASTE FROM OUR
URBAN AREAS AND THIS BILL WILL
SUPPORT THAT PROCESS AS WELL
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING JUST SIGH YOUNG ON
BEHALF OF THE BIO ENERGY
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA --
BACK IS IN SUPPORT OF THIS
MEASURE THANK.
THANK YOU AND MICHAEL BOCA DOOR
OKAY HALF OF THE AG ENERGY
CONSUMERS ASSOCIATION -- OUR
MEMBERS ARE BUILDING MANY OF THE
BILE NOTHING WE'VE GOT FIFTY A
PROJECTS IN VARIOUS STAGES OF
PRODUCTION IN CALIFORNIA.
THEY PROVIDE SIGNIFICANT
BENEFITS NOT JUST TO BUY METHANE
AND REDUCTION OF SHORT LIVED
CLIMATE POLLUTANTS AND HELPING
THE STATE ACHIEVEMENTS GHG.
THEY'RE ALSO PROVIDING
TREMENDOUS ENVIRONMENTAL
BENEFITS CRITERIA POLLUTANT
REDUCTIONS.
THROUGH THEREPLACEMENT OF
DIESEL WITH RENEWABLE NATURAL
GAS AND TRUCKS AND ANOTHER SOME
OPPOSITION THAT'S GOING TO
TESTIFY.
ALL AND THERE AND BE HAPPY TO
RESPOND TO SOME OF THE
OPPOSITION SHOULD THERE BE
QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU THANKS FOR COMING
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT.
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION.
VVC IN LEADERSHIP COUNCIL FOR
JUSTICE AND ACCOUNTABILITY -- A
A JUST A COUPLE OF THINGS OF
NOTE -- I I THINK THAT WOULD
LIKE TO BETTER UNDERSTAND WHY
THIS EXTENSION IS IS NECESSARY.
ALREADY A HALF A BILLION DOLLARS
IN SUBSIDIES.
HAVE GONE OUT THE DOOR FOR
DERRIDA JESTERS IN THE LAST FEW
YEARS IN CALIFORNIA AND IT'S
IT'S UNCLEAR WHY WE NEED TO
EXTEND THIS PROGRAM THE EXTENT
TO WHICH THAT FORTY MILLION
DOLLARS IS CAPTURED.
IN THAT HALF BILLION AND THE
REASONS WHY WE'RE HAVING TROUBLE
GETTING THIS MONEY OUT THE DOOR
I THINK -- ARE AT ONE OF OUR
PRIMARY ISSUES PRIMARY POINTS IS
THAT WHILE WE'RE STILL IN KIND
OF THE DEVELOPMENT MODE AND AND
AND AND TROUBLE SHOOTING AND THE
DIETARY DIGESTION PROGRAM.
IT SEEMS REASONABLE TO PAUSE AT
THIS POINT.
AND STOP PUTTING MORE AND MORE
MONEY INTO THIS INDUSTRY -- AS I
SAID CAN MORE THAN HALF A
BILLION DOLLARS HAS ALREADY BEEN
COMMITTED -- AND WOULD LIKE TO
SEE MORE DOLLARS INVESTED INTO
REAL CLEAN ENERGY PROGRAMS BY A
METHANE IS NOT A CLEAN ENERGY
ALTERNATIVE.
AND WOULD LIKE TO SEE THIS
COMMITTEE AND THE LEGISLATURE
MOVE IN THE DIRECTION OF
INVESTING IN REAL CLEAN ENERGY.
THANKS SO MUCH YOU [inaudible]
ANYONE ELSE.
JULIE JORDAN HERE TODAY
REPRESENTING CALIFORNIA
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE ALLIANCE --
THIS BILL MAY APPEAR TO SIMPLY
JUST EXTEND THE SUNSET BUT IN
REALITY IT SUPPORTS THE PHYSICAL
MONETARY GAS INFRASTRUCTURE THAT
HINDERS CALIFORNIA'S PROGRESS
TOWARDS TRULY CLEAN AND
SUSTAINABLE ENERGY.
BY OMITTING IS NOT A CLEAN FUEL
IT CAPITALIZE ON UNSUSTAINABLE
LARGE SCALE HIGHLY POLLUTING
DAIRY INDUSTRIES THAT CURRENTLY
DOMINATE THE STATE.
POLLUTE AIR AND CONTAMINATE
WATER AND NEGATIVELY IMPACTS
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES LIVING
IN RURAL AREAS NEAR DIE JESTERS
AND OTHER FACILITIES.
BY CONTINUING TO SUPPORT THE
POLICY IN INFRASTRUCTURE FOR BIO
GAS WE ARE ONLY PROLONGING THE
EFFECTS OF DAMAGING FACTORY FARM
PRACTICES AND INCENTIVIZING
LARGER AND LARGER DAIRIES.
IN LARGER HERDS SIZES AND IN
TURN INCREASED ENTERICA MISSIONS
WHICH ARE HALF OF THE METHANE
PROBLEM.
SO I US FOR MY COLLEAGUE IN
OPPOSING SB FOUR FIFTY SEVEN
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
WHAT IS YOUR CHAIR MEMBERS
JENNIFER FEARING ON BEHALF OF
CENTER FOR FOOD SAFETY A LINE MY
COMMENTS WITH THOSE OF OUR
COLLEAGUES IN OPPOSITION TO THIS
BILL THANK YOU?
THANK YOU.
REBECCA MARKETS REPRESENTING
FOOD AND WATER WATCH ALSO A
LINER COMMENTS WITH OUR
COLLEAGUES.
LAUREN CALLING ON BEHALF OF
SIERRA CLUB CALIFORNIA ALSO
LINER COMMENTS WITH MY
COLLEAGUES OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE.
MANY OF MY COLLEAGUES HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS SENATOR STROM THANK
YOU.
MISTER VICE CHAIR AND SENATOR WE
SO I JUST WANT TO APPLAUD YOU
FOR EXTENDING THIS -- SUNSET --
SEE OUR IN OUR IS IN PARIS I
DON'T GET THE OPPORTUNITY TO TO
VISIT THE THIRD AYE CHESTER.
BUT IT'S AN AMAZING SET UP THAT
THEY WERE THE BENEFICIARIES SOME
OF THESE FUNDS AND THEY ARE
CONNECTED TO SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
GAS LINES BUT WHAT'S EVEN MORE
IMPORTANTLY. FOR FOR ME AND
PROBABLY MANY OF US THAT ARE
CONCERNED ABOUT THE ENVIRONMENT
IS IT.
ALL OF THEIR TRASH TRUCKS IN
RIVERSIDE COUNTY FOR ALL THE
MUNICIPALITIES IF THEY SERVE.
IS -- FUELED BY THE NATURAL GAS
THAT THEY CREATE ONSITE.
SO THAT'S A GREAT TESTIMONIAL
FOR WORK FOR YOU AND FOR THIS
BILL AND I'D LIKE TO MOVE IT TO
THE PROPER TIME AND BE OUT TO US
AT A LOCAL AUTHOR IF I COULD.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP ON
THIS.
CENTER STONE CENTER GOD I'M I
JUST LIKE TO ASK YOU A QUESTION.
IF YOU DON'T IF.
YEAH I I DON'T KNOW WHAT THE
OPPOSITION WOULD WANT TO DO WITH
THE THE WAYS FROM THESE DAIRY
OPERATIONS NO FRANKLY I LOOK AT
THIS AND SAY.
YEAH THIS IS AN OPPORTUNITY TO
TAKE WHAT WE ALREADY HAVE WHAT
WERE ALREADY USING WERE
CONSUMING WE HEARD ABOUT SHORT
TERM CLIMATE POLLUTANTS.
WE HEARD ABOUT THE IMPORTANCE OF
THAT WE'VE HEARD ABOUT THAT FOR
YEARS.
IN A IN I I JUST INTERESTED IN
YOUR YOUR YOUR YOUR THOUGHT
PROCESS ON IF NOT THIS WEEK WHAT
DO YOU DO WITH THAT THAT THE
INDUSTRY.
THANKS FOR YOUR QUESTION I WOULD
LOVE -- TED IF YOU'D BE WILLING
TO GOING TO MEET WITH US TO TALK
A LITTLE BIT MORE ABOUT HOW WE
FEEL.
AND WE COULD CAN BETTER ADDRESS
THAT THE AG INDUSTRY IN THE
CLEAN ENERGY -- ECONOMY.
IN SHORT -- THERE'S AT A FALSE
CHOICE THAT WE'RE FACED WITH
WITH RESPECT -- TO ALLOWING AND
MANY WERE PETS TO CONTINUE TO
FESTER AN OFF GAS OR INVESTING
IN DIGEST THERE'S THERE'S OTHER
ALTERNATIVES ARE THE ALTAR OF
THE NEWER MANAGEMENT PROGRAM.
THERE'S THERE'S INVESTING THIS
IN A FIVE HUNDRED BILLION
DOLLARS TO FIVE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS AND COUNTING.
INTO TRANSITIONING TO NOT JUST
CLEAN ENERGY THE MORE
SUSTAINABLE FUNDING PRACTICES OR
NOT -- ACTUALLY PRODUCING
METHANE PREVENTING THAT THE
CREATION OF METHANE WHICH ALTER
OF ENORMOUS MANAGEMENT PRACTICES
DO -- AND THAT WE COULD BE
THINKING BIGGER AND TAKING
BETTER AS CALIFORNIANS
[inaudible]
DR.
S. THE MISTER BOGARD TO RESPOND
TO THAT.
CERTAINLY ON THE DAIRY
INDUSTRY'S BEEN WORKING
DILIGENTLY WITH THE STATE SINCE
THE PASSAGE OF THIRTEEN EIGHTY
THREE TO REDUCE METHOD.
AND THAT'S GOING TO REQUIRE ALL
WHOLE ALL HANDS ON DECK APPROACH
AND WERE VERY SUPPORTIVE OF BOTH
THE ALTERNATIVE MANURE
MANAGEMENT PRACTICE PROGRAM THAT
ON THE SEAT REFERENCE.
WERE ALSO VERY SUPPORTIVE OF THE
DAILY DIGEST A PROGRAM.
ME JUST SAY ONE THING ABOUT THE
DERRY DIGESTED PROGRAM QUICKLY.
IT IS THE SINGLE MOST EFFECTIVE
PROGRAM THAT IS STATE IS
INVESTING GDR UP DOLLARS AND
TODAY.
THE CHEATING OR EXPECTED TO
ACHIEVE MORE REDUCTIONS IN ANY
OTHER PROGRAM RECEIVING
INVESTMENTS.
AND IT'S A PROGRAM THAT IS THE
SECOND MOST COST EFFECTIVE IT
DOWN PROVIDING REDUCTION SAID
ABOUT SEPP EVERY EIGHT TO NINE
DOLLARS A STATE AND BASS.
WE GET A TON A REDUCTION IT'S
ALL METHOD.
WHICH MEANS THAT SHORT LIVE
WHICH MEANS WE'RE GOING TO SEE
THE BENEFITS QUICKER THIS IS A
GREAT PROGRAM.
AND THE FACT THAT WE'RE TAKING
THE BIO GAS AND TURNING IT INTO
TRANSPORTATION FUEL IT'S CLEAN
BURNING THEY CAN REPLACE DIESEL
AND TRUCKS AS MR STONE MENTIONED.
SO WHAT'S HAPPENING IN RIVERSIDE
COUNTY CAN HAPPEN IN THE SAN
JOAQUIN VALLEY SO WE CAN EXTEND
THE BENEFITS.
IT'S TREMENDOUS I THINK SENATOR
MCCAIN MCGUIRE.
I SPOKE ABOUT THIS IN COMMITTEE
LAST WEEK I'M THESE AE GREAT
PROGRAMS THAT ARE BEING
IMPLEMENTED WE NEED TO CONTINUE.
THERE'S NO WAY TO ACHIEVE THE
40% REDUCTION IN MANURE MATH IN
THE STATE'S LOOKING FOR WITH THE
ALTERNATIVE MANURE MANAGEMENT
PROGRAM WE NEED THE DIGESTIVE
PROGRAM AS WELL [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
SENATOR MCGUIRE.
THANK YOU CENTER DOT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND I'LL
BE VERY BRIEF MISTER CHAIR AT
LOOK -- WHAT MISTER BURGER --
JUST SAID WE TAKE A LOOK.
AT THE MANURE MANAGEMENT FINDING
AS WELL AS THE FINDING.
OUT FOR LARGER TEARS WERE IN
FRONT OF BUDGET SOUTH AND WHAT
MR -- LAST THURSDAY WHAT MISTER
PROCTOR -- JESS SAID IN REGARDS
TO THE BIG GET THE BEST BANG FOR
OUR BUCK IN THE STATE IN REGARDS
TO OUR REDUCTION GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS IT'S ABSOLUTELY THE
DERRY JUDGE GESTURES WISEMAN OR
MANAGEMENT.
THE BIGGEST CHALLENGES THAT WE
CURRENTLY HAVE IN THE STATE IS
KEEPING DERRY'S IN BUSINESS IN
CALIFORNIA.
I AND WE HAVE A ISSUED UNDER
THIRTEEN EIGHTY THREE A MANDATE.
TWO YEARS AGO THAT WAS FUNDED
AND NOW WE'RE LOOKING AT CUT
BACKS OUT TO THE FUNDING THAT
WAS COMMITTED TO YEARS AGO SO --
THE LEAST AT THIS LEGISLATURE
CAN DO IS STEP UP PARTICULAR FOR
FAMILY FARMERS AT TO BE A
SUPPORT AND WHEN I ALSO SAY.
YOU TAKE A LOOK AT THOSE DAIRIES
THAT ARE THREE HUNDRED CALS OUR
LAST THE VAST MAJORITY ACROSS
THE STATE I MIGHT ADD.
THERE JACK GESTURES MAY NOT BE
THE THE RIGHT FIT BUT THEY ARE
THE RIGHT FIT FOR FEEDLOTS
INDOOR LARGER GERRY'S INSPECTION
THE NORTH COAST FOR ORGANIC WE
NEED WE ARE HAVE THE NEWER
MANAGEMENT SO.
I THINK THIS IS THE LEAST WE CAN
DO APPRECIATE THE WORK THAT'S
GONE INTO AT THIS BILL AS WELL
AND I WANT TO SAY THANK YOU THE
AUTHOR.
Q. CENTER REQUIRE THANKS FOR
USING THE TERM A NEWER
APPRECIATED.
THE BILL HAS ALREADY HAVE A
MOTION I BELIEVE.
DO I HAVE ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS.
THEN -- MADAM SURGERY IS TAKE
THE ROLE [inaudible]
NOW.
SURE GO AHEAD SENATOR I THINK
CENTER LOWER MADE MY CLOSING
COMMENT. FOR THOSE COMMENTS.
THIS IS MY THANK YOU AND I
APPRECIATE YOUR SUPPORT TODAY --
SP FOUR FIFTY SEVEN DO PASSED
APPROPRIATIONS LESS SO I WAS SO-I MORE LOT HI MORE LIKE I A
BRADFORD CHIANG.
HANG AYE DODD DIED I'VE
HERTZBERG.
HILL HILL AYE MCGUIRE MCGUIRE
AYE RUBIO.
RUBIO AYE SKINNER STERN.
STONE STONE AYE WIENER.
WIENER AYE.
THAT PASSES WILL HOLD
[inaudible]
ALL OPEN [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
AND THAT TAKES US TO SENATE BILL
FIVE OH SIX UNDER WAY SO YOU
HAVE TO FORGET.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR -- I'D
LIKE TO UP PERCENT FIVE ORSIX
WHICH REINSTATES THE AUTHORITY
OF THE ATTORNEY GENERAL TO
REPRESENT THE DEPARTMENT F
FINANCE.
AND TO EXERCISE THE POWERS OF
THE NOW DEFUNCT ELECTRICITY
ELECTRICITY OVERSIGHT BOARD.
IN ESSENCE -- WE HOT WE STILL
HAVE [inaudible]
A LAWSUIT.
ARE THERE ARE THERE ARE ONGOING
THERE ARE PRODUCT OF THE THE
ENERGY CRISIS OF 200-012-0002.
THOSE LAWSUITS ARE OF
REPRESENTING FOR VARIOUS
DIFFERENT AGENCIES OF THE STATE.
INCLUDING THE ELECTRICITY
OVERSIGHT BOARD WHICH IT NO
LONGER EXISTS BUT IS A PARTY TO
THIS LAWSUIT THIS.
BILL WOULD CONTINUE TO GIVE THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL.
THE THE AUTHORITY TO REPRESENT --
THE STATE AGENCIES INCLUDING
THIS ONE THAT IS NOT --
CURRENTLY OF IN EXISTENCE FOR A
PARTY TO THIS VERY IMPART PART
LAWSUIT THAT IS ATTENDING TO
RECOVER.
DAMAGES TO RATE PAYERS -- GOING
BACK -- UP. FIFTEEN YEARS SO --
OF I I'D LIKE TO ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT IN IN ALLOWING OUR
TOURNEY GENERAL TO CONTINUE. TO
REPRESENT THE REPAIRS FOR
CALIFORNIA.
THERE YOU GO.
I AM SENATE HUESO DO YOU HAVE
ANY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
[inaudible]
YES GIVEN.
THE MOTION OF MAYBE IF YOU WANNA
ASK PUBLIC. TO MAKE A COMMENT WE
WOULD LOVE TO HAVE INDIVIDUAL
SUPPORTING YOUR BILL COME.
THANK YOU FOR HOMELESSNESS
RICHARD IF THEY WISH TO KEEP IT
BRIEF THAT WOULD BE SUPER RIGHT
WONDERFUL.
JUST TO BE ON RECORD MARIO
DIBERNARDO WITH THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL'S OFFICE ATTORNEY
GENERAL.
SERRA IS THE SPONSOR THIS BILL
WE THINK THE CENTER FOR CARRYING
THIS AND THANK YOU COMMITTEE
MEMBERS WE ARE DRIVE UP.
THANK YOU.
REBECCA LEE ON BEHALF OF
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA EDISON WITH
THIS SUBMITTED A SUPPORT LETTER
YESTERDAY AND JUST THE COST
IMPACT TO EDISON CUSTOMER ALONE
JUST WITH THIS YEAR.
IS FOR THE COSTS INCURRED DURING
THE ENERGY CRISIS IS THREE
HUNDRED AND EIGHTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS SO ANY COMPENSATION WE
CAN GET BACK FROM THESE
LITIGATION WOULD HELP TRIM DOWN
THOSE COSTS BIRD THANK YOU.
MORE COMMON BE OUT OF SIERRA
CLUB CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT THIS
BILL.
GREAT ANY OTHER IN SUPPORT ANY
IN OPPOSITION.
PLEASE LINE UP INTO THE HALLWAY.
I HAVE A TO MOTIONS MAYBE.
THREE WOULD YOU LIKE TO
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT THANK YOU SIR.
I I'M I WAS UP PRETTY BUSY AT
THIS TIME -- IS A TREASURE WITH
THE ENERGY CRISIS SO IT'S
AMAZING THAT IT STILL.
I MEAN TO MAKE SUCH A DISTANT
MEMORY BUT IT'S STILL ALIVE
TODAY.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
SB FIVE OH SIXTY PASSED TO
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE WEST SO.
WITH SO I MORE LOT I MORE LIKE
AYE BRADFORD.
BRADFORD I CHING CHANG AYE DODD.
DIED I HEARD [inaudible]
HILL.
HILL AYE MCGUIRE.
MCGUIRE AYE RUBIO.
RUBIO AYE SKINNER STERN DOWN.
DOWN AYE WIENER WIENER AYE.
WELL -- WILL HOLD AN OPEN AS
WELL FOR THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
MR KERRY YOU'RE BACK IN CONTROL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE'RE GONNA
OPEN THE ROLE NOW ON ON ON
TODAY'S AGENDA TURN CAPS AND
MEMBERS BEGINNING [inaudible]
WITH.
SB -- FOUR FIVE SEVEN PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
THE PASTOR APPROPRIATIONS KIND
VOTE NINE ZERO BRADFORD.
BRADFORD AYE SKINNER STERN.
WELL HOLD IT OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS -- SB FIVE ZERO SIX ITEM
NUMBER.
TWO CLICK PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS THE PAST YOU TODAY
SHERRY COMMITTEE CURRENT BUT TEN
ZERO HERTZBERG.
SCANNER STERN [inaudible]
THIS IS.
WE'LL KEEP THE ROLE OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS -- ITEM NUMBER
THREE SB.
FIVE ONE FIVE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS PLEASE GIVE PASSES
AMENDED TO THE RULES COMMITTEE
CURRENT VOTE SEVEN ZERO MORE LOT.
ALL RIGHT MORE LIKE I CHIANG
CHIANG AYE HERTZBERG.
HILL.
HILL AYE MCGUIRE.
MCGUIRE AYE SKINNER.
WHEN THE ON CALL?
OKAY WILL LEAVE THE ROLE OF
LIVES THE ROLE OF NUMBER FILL
OUT WILL MOVE ON TO SP -- FOUR
SEE IF I ITEM FOR SB.
FIVE TO FOUR CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS DAY PASSES AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONSCOMMITTEE CURRENT
VOTE NINE ONE MORE LOT.
MORE LIKE NO BRADFORD.
BRADFORD AYE.
SKINNER.
LEAVE THE ROLE OF PUBLIC SAFETY
IS ITEM NUMBER -- FIVE THE
CONSENT CALENDAR.
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
DO YOU PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS SB
FIVE FOUR EIGHT MORE A LOT.
MORE LIKE AYE BRADFORD BRADFORD
AYE SKINNER.
ITEM NUMBER SIX SB SIX SEVENTY
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS YOU PASS
A GOVERNMENTAL ORGAN STATION
COMMITTEE CURRENT VOTE TEN ZERO
BRADFORD.
BRADFORD AYE SKINNER
[inaudible]
HERTZBERG [inaudible]
WE'RE BURKE
.
FROM WHERE.
ENOUGH.
OFFERS OFFICE YEAH YEAH.
HEY LOOK HERE AND
ONE THIS CALL
THE ROLL.
SB FIVE OR FOUR FIVE SEVENTY
PASTOR APPROPRIATIONS. FOR ABOUT
TEN ZERO HERTZBERG.
SKINNER RIGHT SKINNER AYE STERN.
ITEM TO PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS.
SB FIVE A SIXTY PASSED TO
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE ABOUT TEN
ZERO HERTZBERG SKINNER
[inaudible]
I STERN.
ITEM THREE PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS SB FIVE ONE FIVE
TWO PASSED AMENDED TO RULES
COMMITTEE CURRENT VOTE ELEVEN
ZERO HERTZBERG SKINNER RIGHT
SKINNER I PLEASE CALL OBSERVERS
LETTER [inaudible]
THREE AM [inaudible]
YEAH.
HERTZBERG HI Q. COLLAPSE OF
MEMBERS AND ITEM.
ONE SB FOUR FOUR FIVE SEVEN
HERTZBERG.
HERTZBERG AYE STERN ON ITEM.
TO PLEASE CUSTOMERS AN ITEM.
TO SB FIVE OR SIX YOU PASSED TO
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE HERTZBERG.
AYE HERTZBERG AYE STERN.
PLEASE CALL ABSENT MEMBERS AN
ITEM.
FOR SB FIVE TO FOUR G. PASSED
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE CURRENT VOTE.
AND TO SKINNER FIVE SKINNER I ON
THE CONSENT CALENDAR PLEASE CUPS
OF MEMBERS SB FIVE FOUR EIGHT DO
YOU PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS
CURRENT BUT TWELVE ZERO SKINNER
FIVE SKINNER I A COMMUNITY CALL
HERTZBERG.
YEAH.
HE COULD [inaudible]
HOW?
SECOND ALSO QUITE.
WHY?
YEAH AS FAR AS POSSIBLE.
I AM SIX PLAYS ACOSTA MEMBERS SB
SIX SEVEN ZERO DO PASSED TO
GOVERNMENTAL ORGANIZATION
COMMITTEE CURRENT PHOTO LEVIN
ZERO HERTZBERG.
HERTZBERG AYE SKINNER ALL RIGHT
SKINNER I VERY WELL WILL --
CLOSE ROLE WILL ADJOURN THE
MEETING